[Musique]
Pascal Boniface bonsoir bonsoir nous
vous recevons pour une chaîne internet
qui s'appelle thinkerview nous sommes en
direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succinctement oui je m'appelle
Pascal bonifat j'ai 66 ans je suis
universitaire et je suis directeur et
fondateur de l'iris l'Institut de
relations internationale stratégiques
qui est un film tank un centre de
recherche sur les questions géopolitique
qui en même temps aussi une école
iRISUP pour de formation sur ces
questions là voilà à peu près à grand
tresse qui peut me définir donc on a
décidé de vous convier aujourd'hui pour
parler géopolitique bien entendu parler
des grands sujets qui vont nous crisper
dans les semaines des mois et les années
à venir
avant de commencer par les techniques
insignitant que ça sert à quoi ça fait
comment qu'est-ce qui peuple se signe
donc là comment on fait pour recruter
les gens est-ce que c'est pas à peu près
toujours la même le même public qui
s'intéresse à ce type de sujet je vous
écoute alors en fait il y a fington qui
a une très grande diversité le film tank
c'est comme vous le devinez une
définition américaine un réservoir
d'idées donc en fait ça a été écrit aux
États-Unis les gens ont dit on va créer
en dehors d'administration des
réservoirs d'idées qui sont pas à
l'université c'est encore autre chose et
qui peuvent librement chercher sur des
sujets et donc il peut y avoir des films
d'angle sur tous les sujets sur
l'économie sur les questions sociales
donc en fait c'est un centre de
recherche non universitaire qui n'est
pas reliée directement à l'université
comment recrute moi je peux vous
répondre pour l'iris mais après les
autres chacun a ses modes parce que
comme vous devinez de même qu'est-ce
qu'un journal qu'est-ce qu'un film tank
qu'est-ce qu'un parti politique
il y a vraiment avoir choisi ces deux
professions comme journaliste et
politiques est-ce que les signes temples
ne seraient pas maintenant devenues plus
des groupes d'influences plutôt que des
réservoirs d'idées depuis le départ
depuis le départ c'est en fait réservoir
d'idées c'est aussi pour exercer de
l'influence les idées sont là pour
influencer donc effectivement je voulais
dire par là c'est que en fait il y a pas
une sorte de corporation unie parce que
chacun son identité vous avez aussi
beaucoup de faux films tank quelqu'un
qui met centre mondial de lutte contre
le recherche sur le terrorisme il y a
bon voilà vous pouvez vous pouvez bon il
faut voir un peu je crois que la
différence c'est
ceux qui ont une activité de publication
d'organisation d'événements de coloc qui
ont une visibilité qui ne se résume pas
à une personne il faut allez voir par
rapport à l'antériorité de leurs
anticipations ce qu'on voit beaucoup je
vais prendre l'exemple de la guerre en
Irak
on a vu beaucoup de signes tant qu'un
petit peu partir en drift avec des
analystes qui étaient complètement à
côté de la plaque mais on les voit
toujours dans nos médias maintenant ils
sont toujours là aux États-Unis c'est
pire puisque
Stéphane Walt a écrit un livre qui
s'appelle l'enfer des bonnes intentions
où il dit que les quelques spécialistes
qui étaient opposés à guerre d'Irak en
2003 non j'aime pas fait de carrière et
tous ceux qui l'ont soutenu qui ont
appelé on fait des super carrières mais
en France c'est pareil vous avez
effectivement des gens qui nous ont
raconté que la guerre quel malheur
mettait quand même nécessaire parce que
il y avait des armes de discussion
massive en Irak et soit ils étaient peu
compétents soit ils étaient sous
influence les mêmes d'ailleurs on dit à
partir de 2005 que l'Iran était à 6 mois
de l'arme nucléaire 17 ans plus tard
l'Iran a toujours pas l'arme nucléaire
donc il y a un petit problème mais en
fait vous savez c'est dans les films
d'angle comme pour dans d'autres
professions même les écrits s'envolent
fallait pas que les paroles et
effectivement
si vous êtes bien introduit que vous
êtes en orbite vous redescendez pas et
donc introduit bien en orbite si vous
êtes si vous avez une surface sociale
importante
si vous êtes bien établi que vous venez
des bons milieux des bonnes écoles etc
si vous vous fâchez pas voilà aussi
il y a aussi une dimension excusez-moi
d'être vulgaire il y a aussi une
dimension il faut faire de la lèche
disons alors il y a des spécialistes il
y a des gens effectivement qui adorent
ça après il y a aussi une sorte d'entre
soi bon moi j'ai eu beaucoup de
problèmes quand j'ai fait un bouquin qui
s'appelle faussaire parce que j'ai pas
joué voilà vous avez la règle c'est si
vous êtes une Sider vous critiquez pas
les autres Insider
parce que sinon vous brisez la règle et
dire bah on peut dire des conneries mais
on reste entre nous et puis on peut se
retrouver et puis j'aurais besoin de toi
plus tard et puis bah voilà machin peut
me rendre service faire renvoi
d'ascenseur donc si comme je l'ai fait
dans ce livre il y a des gens qui nous
ont baratinés qui ont dit qu'il fallait
faire la guerre parce que ça allait
éviter un malheur mais en fait ça
construit ça conduit un malheur et donc
on peut quand même remettre en cause
leur légitimité comme chercheur et ben
là en fait je me suis fait plus mal voir
et je vais dire je suis depuis par
exemple interdit d'antenne sur France
Inter France Culture le monde tandis que
ces gens-là continuent à y aller donc en
fait voilà non il y a pas il y a pas une
sorte de récompense au fait
l'intégrité ou le fait de ne pas trop se
tromper ne joue pas bon vous êtes dans
le circuit vous aussi dans le circuit
récemment vous êtes fait
comment on pourrait dire ça c'est lire
scène qui vous a qualifié d'être relié
de Pékin c'est ça exactement mais on les
lisait on avait l'impression que vous
faisiez le canard avec qui en cuisine
vous savez j'ai le cuire un peu tanné
parce que j'ai été accusé susceptivement
d'être payé par les Émirats arabes unis
par les Arabes par les pays du Golfe par
le Qatar par les Turcs par les Chinois
par les Russes je dois en oublier
du côté de l'Axe du Bien ah non pourtant
on a aussi bossé avec des États-Unis
poste ambassade américaine mais là il y
a jamais ce type d'accusation
effectivement c'est que si vous êtes
relié à et même financer par les jamais
on va vous le reprocher parce que c'est
normal vous faites partie du même club
c'est en fait dès que vous sortez alors
la Turquie c'est un pays qui est pas
tout à fait occidental mais dès que vous
sortez de l'OTAN là bon vous pouvez
vraiment être sous influence américaine
on vous dira rien parce que ça fait
partie de la famille et puis moi
j'appartiens à un milieu dans le dans la
communauté stratégique
c'est pas seulement que les gens sont
payés il y a des gens qui sincèrement
quand vous parlez toujours au même genre
que vous allez toujours dans les mêmes
colocs ça fait 30 ans vous faites l'OTAN
à la croisée des chemins
voilà vous pensez que le temps était la
croisée des chemins et en fait vous
connaissez les gens ils sont
sympathiques ils vous reçoivent bien moi
j'étais en 85 j'étais encore un jeune
chercheur je la peine de terminer ma
thèse j'étais invité par un programme
formidable aux États-Unis pendant un
mois j'avais un accompagnateur tout
était payé je pouvais même faire
quelques trucs de tourisme Le Grand
Canyon Las Vegas etc je voyais des des
différents films tank bon chance de tel
était garni ou pas non non non
et non c'est pas les méthodes de des
États-Unis et c'est une méthode russe
mais malheureusement ou heureusement je
sais pas enfin moi j'ai jamais eu une
chambre garnie et en aussi en Chine mais
bon je dois pas être un assez gros
poisson j'imagine et en tous les cas et
donc effectivement on se sent appartenir
à une communauté
et quand vous voyez toujours les mêmes
personnes vous appartenez à une famille
donc vous allez pas vous fâcher avec les
membres de la famille parce que vous
allez vous revoir parce que et donc au
fur et à mesure vous devez être un petit
peu de plus en plus influencé finalement
et en fait après vous vous auto
persuadez que c'est dans ce sens là
qu'il faut aller et si vous ne frottez
pas alors maintenant ça change un peu
parce que c'est vrai que quand moi j'ai
commencé à bosser sur la question
stratégique au début des années 80 il y
avait des films tanks en Europe pas
beaucoup en France mais c'est les
États-Unis maintenant il y a dans
d'autres domaines vous en avez en Chine
vous avez on n'avait pas contact avec
les pays non-occidentaux maintenant vous
avez fait une tank un peu partout mais
il y avait quand même une sorte de
monopole de fait
la reconnaissance disons que les
Français qui travaillaient sur les
questions stratégiques étaient un peu
les provinciaux par rapport à la
capitale qui était les États-Unis si on
était connu par un film tank américain
par une revue américaine c'est le Graal
c'était vraiment la l'onction etc et
donc si on vous reconnaît et si on vous
dit venez à la table on vous invite et
que on le fait gentiment et qui a des
bains intéressants par ailleurs qui a
une vraie liberté de ton bah voilà vous
faites partie de la famille au fur et à
mesure vous adoptez les modes de pensée
de du centre quand vous dites une
liberté de ton en parlant de la famille
si vous aviez prononcé cette phrase là
avec l'accent italien
ça aurait pris une autre dimension quand
même non
vous savez il y a des communautés un peu
partout donc on se sent appartenir à un
club et donc on n'a pas envie de briser
les règles de ce club liberté de ton
c'est aussi la liberté de se fâcher ah
oui mais là pas tout à fait ça que c'est
vrai que quand vous allez aux États-Unis
vous voyez aussi des gens de
l'opposition vous avez des gens qui sont
pas d'accord avec le gouvernement vous
avez des gens qui etc donc ça c'est très
plaisant regardez au début des années 90
tous les tous mes collègues
universitaires qui bossaient sur les
questions internationales ils étaient
polonais tchécoslovaque etc tous ces
gens là ils pouvaient que répéter les
éléments de langage fournis par l'Union
soviétique au début et puis après tout
d'un coup tout ça s'arrête et ils sont
invités par les pays de l'OTAN à l'OTAN
même et le temps a fait un grand
programme il venait il pouvait critiquer
tout le monde c'était génial ils avaient
un petit père dit aime c'est confortable
etc ils sont dit c'est génial le temps
c'est génial je suis libre de critiquer
y compris ce qui m'invite etc ils sont
devenus de vrais believeurs ils ont été
effectivement ils se sont convertis avec
la fougue et donc les faits séduction a
marché à fond et c'est pas étonnant que
les anciens pays de l'Est soient les
plus pro-américains alors il y a
l'histoire qui explique cela mais aussi
disons il y a eu quand même l'influence
ça existe ça existe est-ce que
comme dirait l'OTAN l'axe du mal ne sait
pas inspiré aussi de ces méthodes là on
vous apprenchant vous on vous tamponnant
vous avec l'ambassade de Chine est-ce
que c'était pas je me fais l'avocat
pliable est-ce que c'était pas vous qui
partiez pour chasser mais en fait vous y
retrouver comme proie ah ben c'est clair
que l'ambassade de Chine a dû remarquer
que je ne répétais pas les aimants de
langage de l'OTAN et donc en même temps
l'ambassade de Chine à cette époque
travaillait avec d'autres films d'angle
plus classiques je dirais plus dans la
ligne donc bon c'était aussi en fait on
nous a reproché d'avoir fait des
séminaires sur la route de l'espoir
c'était la période 2017-2018-2019 à une
époque où Trump était au pouvoir ou la
Chine travaille avec la France la
question climat sur les questions aussi
du nucléaire iranien etc et donc on
avait les points d'accord et
l'accusation qui a été portée c'est que
on n'avait jamais critiqué
ce programme des routes de la soie que
il y avait aucune parole critique on
était les simples relais de la parole
chinoise du coup on a réécouté tous les
débats quand les trois journées et il y
avait plein de critiques qui étaient
émises sur le point le piège de la dette
sur les droits de l'homme etc enfin bon
bref donc mais effectivement oui moi je
suis un peu
considéré comme un peu free rider par
rapport à disons à mes autres petits
camarades
l'iris je l'ai créé tout seul on est
parti avec 20000 balles autour d'un
bouquin en France ancien avant ça a
grossi au fur et à mesure etc donc
mais en tous les cas moi puisque vous
parlez de long parcours moi je plaise la
cohérence de mon parcours c'est à dire
que on peut reprendre auquel je suis
payé par ci par ça etc bah non j'ai une
logique d'analyse des relations
internationales qui est effectivement de
ne traite pas occidentaliste
de ne pas penser qu'il y a le bien et le
mal de ne pas penser que les autres ont
toujours tort et que l'Occident a des
valeurs supérieures aux autres
civilisations bon ça c'est ma cohérence
et donc effectivement les gens du Sud le
voit c'est vrai en fait j'ai vous faire
une prenant je suis payé par les Arabes
tous les seuls par les Arabes ça veut
rien dire ça si si c'est samedi matin au
marché à lire tous les samedis matins
j'ai des fruits gratuits un peu plus que
le poids on réduit mon compte etc j'ai
toujours des petits cadeaux au marché de
la Ligue donc oui là je suis et si ces
gens font ça c'est que ils ne sont
reconnaissants de ne pas avoir à leur
égard un discours d'exclusion ou de choc
des simulations passif
je l'avoue sur votre antenne
et je fais un salut amical au marchand
du marché d'Aligre
on verra si on a les mêmes promotion
maintenant qu'on a fait les
présentations que vous êtes vous vous
décrivez comme un apostar par rapport au
jus que là mais enfin en tous les cas un
livre penseur est-ce que être imposteur
ou libre-penseur ça aide dans la
prospective avoir des prospectives plus
affûtées
plus on va dire une pointe de diamant
plus affûtée par rapport au Rond rond
quotidien des salons feutrés de design
tank alors j'aurais pas donné le
sentiment d'avoir un jugement négatif
sur l'ensemble de mes collègues il y a
quelques aigrefins non parce que il y a
des gens que je respecte il y a des gens
que lesquels je suis en désaccord dont
je reconnais l'intégrité on n'est pas
d'accord et c'est ça le débat c'est très
bien il y a quelques gens qui sont des
faussaires mais il y a des gens juste on
n'est pas d'accord tant mieux c'est très
bien et ils ont parce qu'on vient pas du
même on n'a pas la même formation on n'a
pas le même parcours on n'a pas les
mêmes influences etc et donc voilà alors
oui de toute façon ce qu'il faut
toujours c'est un peu penser en dehors
de la boîte toujours essayer
de se méfier de soi-même
de ne pas de pas être dans la répétition
de toujours puis c'est ça qui est
amusant c'est ça qui est intéressant
parce que moi des fois on me dit bah
quand est-ce que tu prendras la retraite
certains le souhaitent j'imagine
mais en fait moi ce que je fais ça
m'intéresse ça m'intéresse que c'est
jamais pareil et donc tant que j'aurais
des neurones qui fonctionnent je prends
si je gagne au loto je ferai exactement
la même chose je vais pas nous faire un
petit don voilà
et donc et c'est aussi une des
conditions c'est d'aller
parce que si vous dites toujours la même
chose prendre un exemple des fois il y a
des sujets que je connais vraiment assez
bien je crois donc si on me demande un
papier voilà c'est c'est fait en de
couler gros bon il y a des formes de
mentir ça fait chier je et puis en fait
après je suis content parce que ça me
pousse un peu à sortir de mes
retranchements j'essaie de ne pas aller
sur des sujets sur lesquels j'ai aucune
légitimité mais il y a des fois des
sujets qui sont un peu Inter violent etc
donc oui effectivement
je veux dire les rondes cuir ce qui
répètent le même principe préchard
depuis des années
c'est pas extrêmement performant sauf
que c'est pas performant sauf que nos
dirigeants
les écoutent seront quotidiens véhicules
et depuis des décennies de passivité
intellectuelle d'arrangement avec la la
pertinence intellectuelle de la
prospective la pertinence de quelque
chose qui est bossé sans dogme nos
politiques sont amis à être conseillés
par seront quotidien et ça ça génère
peut-être des mauvaises décisions par
notre appareil d'étatique alors aux
États-Unis c'est clair parce qu'on dit
il y a jamais dans aucun pays autant de
film tank mais leur conclusion sont
tenues par ceux qui les finances donc
c'est pas liberté en France on peut
aussi le cas non comment ceux qui les
finances détiennent aussi les cordons
oui c'est ça voilà ouais donc bon ils
vont pas aller sur le Proche-Orient
faire un truc qui s'écarte trop du
créneau etc en France c'est un peu plus
contrasté parce que des gens les
positions diverses etc et puis vous avez
des responsables qui au contraire
cherchent un peu à sortir
ça dépend des époques je fuite un temps
où effectivement à la tête des organes
officiels et prospectives il y avait des
gens qui n'étaient pas dans la ligne qui
étaient écartés donc on refusait c'est
ça qui a conduit à la disparition de
l'Union soviétique c'est-à-dire que
Gorbatchev raconte que ils avaient fait
une étude avec ses amis avant d'arriver
au pouvoir en disant que si on cotait
comme ça on allait dans le mur ça serait
la Haute Volta avec des fusées on l'a
dit c'est très bien mais changer la
conclusion bon donc effectivement on
peut ne pas voir heureusement il y a des
dirigeants qui essayent un petit peu de
d'imaginer mais après il y a des
lourdeurs bureaucratiques il y a etc
mais ce que Macron appelle l'état
profond oui alors c'est ce qu'il a
appelé l'état profond dans un discours
devant les ambassadeurs en
novembre 2018 de mémoire août 2000 non
pardon en août 2000 enfin si au mois
d'août est-ce que c'est 2018-202 je
crois que c'est 2019 je serai pas sûr
c'est sûr que c'est Macron et c'est sûr
que c'est Macron et il désignait ceux
qui au Quai d'Orsay s'opposaient un peu
de la politique notamment de dialogue
avec la Russie
mais ils sont restés en place
et quelque part alors c'est marrant
quand il a fait son discours on a bien
vu il y avait quelques personnes qui
étaient en PLS ils étaient vraiment de
sécurité parce que j'étais bon d'autres
qui rigolaient bon mais ça n'a pas
changé maintenant d'ailleurs ceux qui
disent voyez on l'avait bien dit qu'il
faut pas négocier avec la Russie la
preuve ils ont agressé l'Ukraine donc
c'est nous qui avions raison on peut
dire à l'inverse à force de ne pas avoir
de la Russie on a une crise passion et
que ça allait boucher sur cela mais il y
a en fait
en politique internationale en France
l'opposition elle est pas en droit de
rentrer droit et gauche elle est entre
ce qu'on appelle les Gaulois
mitterrandistes et auparavant les
atlantistes et maintenant les
néoconsommateurs ou les occidentalistes
les premiers pensent que la France
certes appartient au monde occidental
mais qu'on peut pas la résumer à ça
parce que c'est réduire c'est la réduire
réduire son poids et réduire son
influence
ceux qui pensent qu'ils sont le bien et
que le bien doit triompher et d'autres
qui pensent que il y a des situations
plus complexes que le monde n'est pas
binaire que en fait en réalité
contrairement à ce que ces gens-là
disent le reste du monde ne nous
reproche pas nos valeurs il nous
reproche de ne pas les appliquer de ne
pas être cohérent de ne pas les
appliquer tout le temps qui en dit le
droit de l'homme et on fait Guantanamo
le droit des peuples exposé de même et
on occupe la Palestine et on dit rien
par rapport à cette occupation
et vols secrets de la CIA en Europe
et
territoire bon protège la femme et de
multiples bon on se dit que la France
est payée droits de l'homme on
s'accommode quand même de pratiques qui
sont alors je veux bien que la politique
doit être réaliste ce qui me gêne un peu
c'est qu'on fait la leçon aux autres et
que soi-même on fait du sélectif
et donc c'est ça en fait regardez là par
rapport à la guerre que la Russie a
lancé contre l'Ukraine
à peu près sauf 5 tous les pays ont
condamné l'agression
quelques-uns une trentaine se sont
abstenus par contre quels sont les pays
qui ont pris des sanctions contre la
Russie que les pays occidentaux
tous les autres dans leur diversité qui
soit des régimes autoritaires ou des
démocraties n'ont pas voulu prendre de
sanctions à l'égard de la Russie non pas
qu'ils approuvent l'agression mais
qu'ils en ont marre que ça soit toujours
les Occidentaux qui décident qui doit
être sanctionnés juste peur de s'en
prendre derrière souvent ils s'en sont
pris déjà et puis ils veulent pas
certains ne pas se fâcher avec la Russie
enfin il y a des mais voilà et en fait
il faut se rendre compte du choses c'est
que le monde occidental a perdu le
monopole de la puissance qu'il a exercé
pendant 500 ans
pendant 500 ans pour faire court depuis
ce qu'on appelle à tort les grandes
découvertes on a rien découvert ça
existait avant qu'on arrive enfin ce
terme de grande découverte aussi c'est
quand même un petit peu bon on a dominé
le monde à la fin du 19e siècle Bismarck
peut dire les relations internales c'est
simple il suffit d'être trois contre
deux et que 5 puissances dans le monde à
cette époque l'Empire russe l'Empire
austro-hongrois la Prusse qui va devenir
l'Empire allemand la France est
l'Angleterre et donc voilà on a fixé
l'agenda on a fixé les normes
culturelles politiques etc on a dominé
le monde deux Guillerm guerre mondiale
l'Europe disparaît il s'agit prenne le
relais puis voilà aussi la grande
tragique erreur des Occidentaux c'est
que l'URSS implose on n'a pas voulu des
gambas de chefs à la fin et donc on dit
c'est génial le monde est unipolaire on
a on s'est débarrassé d'un ennemi qui
nous a fait peur pendant 40 à 45 ans
mais les relations SOS elles ont duré
quatre décennies la domination
occidentale du monde 5 siècles donc ça
marque beaucoup plus les consciences des
esprits etc et on n'a pas vu tout
content de regarder qu'à l'Est cela
n'existait plus à cause Sud il y a des
gens qui se levaient et qui
n'acceptaient plus qu'on leur dise voilà
comment il faut faire voilà comment on
les chapitre qu'on leur fasse la leçon
sur les droits de l'homme sans les
respecter tout à fait nous-mêmes etc
alors attention je dis pas que tous les
régimes se valent et que tout est dans
tout il y a des différences mais voilà
le le monde c'est levé l'Occident a
perdu le monopole et parfois il agit
comme s'il l'avait toujours et ça
conduit à des erreurs donc il faut se
rendre compte que le monde est divers et
que si on veut que le reste du monde
applique de façon plus active les
principes que l'on met en avant mais il
faut que nous-mêmes on les applique de
façon plus cohérente et c'est à mon avis
une méthode plus efficace que d'envoyer
des regardez comment
l'Angleterre exporté deux choses le
football et la démocratie et il est
costard oui alors les costards de façon
moins universelle quand même bon le
football ils l'ont pas exporté par la
contrainte
l'empire du football c'est un empire qui
s'est construit pacifiquement dans
l'enthousiasme des peuples conquis par
contre si vous voulez exporter vos
valeurs en disant si vous n'êtes pas
content il y aura un des coups de shlag
pour que les compreniez un peu mieux ça
ne marche pas
il va on va je vais vous poser comme une
dernière question sur les Sims tank les
jeunes qui viennent
pulluler aux portes des signes tanks
pour avoir des stages avoir une bonne
petite carte de visite ou les choses
comme ça c'est quel type de jeûne c'est
c'est du jeune de bonne famille non non
non non non non non non pas du tout
c'est vraiment très divers vous savez
moi j'étais lycéen au Val Fourré à
Mantes-la-Jolie et après j'ai fait mes
études à Villetaneuse donc je ne sors
pas bon et donc non c'est des gens pas
tomber dans la drogue
donc et en fait il y a un peu de tout il
y a effectivement quelques petits
marquis mais aussi des gars qui viennent
des milieux populaires et qui sont
passionnés par ça et surtout qui pense
pas en dehors qui pensent en dehors de
la boîte et qui peuvent amener des
éléments beaucoup plus productifs à la
prospective donc n'hésitez pas revenons
à nos sujets on va parler géopolitique
finance peut-être un peu de terrorisme
peut-être un peu
moins à l'aise enfin pourquoi pas
finance vous parlez un peu finance pas
c'est pas trop mon domaine en fait alors
commençons par la Chine
la Chine où est son proxy parce que on
dit qu'on fait des proxy des guerres par
proxy quel est le proxy de la Chine ou
quels sont les proxy de la Chine on a le
droit de voir en Afrique on a le droit
de voir en Asie on a le droit de voir en
Europe il y a pas de proxy au sens je
dirais classique du terme comme il y
avait des proxis soviétiques ou des
proxy américain il y a des pays sur
lesquels la Chine exerce une influence
de nature diverses selon l'implication
économique la dette le nombre de gens
qui ont formés chez eux les Chinois se
sont mis au soft power
il y a non seulement environ 500
Institut grandfutus
des fois en Afrique y compris dans les
locaux j'étais il y a deux ans au Congo
Brazzaville dans les locaux du ministère
et pas danger il y a un institut confus
et ils invitent pas mal d'étudiants
africains à faire des stages des visites
en Chine donc voilà donc mais il y a pas
un pays qui serait aux ordres il y a pas
la l'Impérium que l'URS savait sur ses
alliés pendant la guerre froide il y a
pas l'équivalent pour la Chine à l'égard
de certains pays même et y compris la
Corée du Nord je dirais même peut-être
surtout la Corée du Nord dont le
comportement en fait en merde royalement
la Chine parce que ça vient perturber
les choses et que les cheval n'aiment
pas les perturbations et que les
multiples essais et gesticulations de la
Corée du Nord sont un prétexte pour que
les Américains renforcent leur présence
militaire en Corée du Sud et c'est
évidemment la chose qui agace le plus
les chinois mais
ils veulent pas que le régime tombe la
Corée du Nord c'est un peu le pour les
Chinois le tonton alcoolique un peu gras
et qui fait partie de la famille qu'on
peut pas expulser mais vraiment quand on
n'est pas fier quoi bon donc j'ai pas
qu'il y a des proxy chinois vous voyez
comme il y a eu des proxy il y a pas de
pays qui va répéter mot à mot les
éléments de langage fournis par
l'ambassade chinoise
côté américain quels sont les proxy des
États-Unis bah il y en a moins qu'avant
quand même parce que regardez certains
pays arabes du golf qui étaient très
liés avec les États-Unis ont refusé de
prendre des sanctions à l'égard de la
Russie donc on peut dire que certains
pays d'Amérique centrale certains pays
des Caraïbes sont disons toujours très
proches mais même en Amérique latine la
doctrine monroeul est terminée même la
Colombie prend des distances par rapport
alors disons que oui les pays les plus
pro-américains c'est les Pays-Bas ta
Pologne parce qu'ils sont terrorisés par
la Russie et qui sont persuadés que seul
la Russie peut les protéger c'est le
Kosovo parce que les États-Unis pardon
peut les protéger pardon ceux-ci peut
les peuvent les protéger contre la
Russie il y a le Kosovo qui est très pro
américain parce qu'il pense que c'est
grâce aux États-Unis c'est le cas
d'ailleurs qu'ils existent de façon
indépendante et que la guerre de 99 a
été une guerre de libération donc il y a
quelques pays comme cela mais pas
avec ça plus tant que ça donc le le les
les pays satellites comme on disait
auparavant sont quand même moins
nombreux qu'est-ce qui se passe avec le
crâne
il se passe d'une part des drames
humains des crimes de guerre qui sont
documentés
il se passe aussi
je pense que voilà on ne peut être que
frappé d'émotion quand on voit les
images mais il faut pas que l'émotion
l'emporte dans l'analyse il faut séparer
émotion il faut pas être un monstre
froid mais on peut pas uniquement
être guidé par l'émotion d'ailleurs je
remarque que quand des fois on entend
c'est la première guerre en Europe
depuis est-ce qu'on dit Guerre mondiale
il y a la guerre du Kosovo en 99 et à
l'époque on avait moins d'image de
réfugiés
on voyait pas les Yougoslaves qui
fuyaient les bombardements il est fuyait
également alors que nos bombes elles
font moins de réfugiés
alors ceci étant il n'y a pas eu les
violences et les crimes de guerre
auxquels l'armée russe se livre en ce
moment
mais pour faire ce donc l'émotion compte
et on peut pas y être insensible mais il
fautnaliser de façon en raison et par
exemple là aussi je pense que l'on peut
dire à la fois que nous avons commis des
erreurs à l'égard de la Russie nous
avons commis des erreurs à l'égard de la
réussite les types d'erreurs
élargissement de l'OTAN et il n'y a pas
que des agences russes qui dit ça
Mitterrand disait ça des 91 en disant si
on élargit longtemps on va crisper la
russienan l'inventeur du concept du
container la même chose le fait de
développer des systèmes de défense
antimissiles qui venait remettre en
cause la parité nucléaire avec la Russie
la guerre du Kosovo qui montrait que le
temps n'était pas qu'une alliance
défensive parce que la USA vie vous avez
pas bon on a mais même quelqu'un pour
qui j'ai le plus grand respect que j'ai
vu régulièrement pendant des années
parce qu'il avait un forum annuel
Gorbatchev Gorbachev ne veut pas être
conseillé comme étant antioxydant
bon il avait par rapport aux Occidentaux
et par rapport aux erreurs occidentales
à l'égard de la Russie les mêmes
reproches que ceux fait par Poutine et
on critiquait Poutine sur son ordre
interne sur sa répression sur son
territorisme mais pas sur la
contestation des Occidentaux mais une
fois qu'on a dit ça
et bien c'est quand même Poutine qui est
responsable de la guerre et les crimes
de guerre sont de la part de la Russie
et c'est les la population civile
ukrainienne qui est bombardée ce n'est
pas la population civile russe qu'il est
et en fait ça revient ils sont fait
bombarder dans le bon basse non alors
oui mais c'est le territoire ukrainien
dont basse officiellement c'est pas la
Russie pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
gouvernement ukrainien sur le territoire
russe et en disant ça ça revient à votre
question de départ parce qu'en ce moment
vous entendez soit des gens qui disent
ah oui mais on a été voilà c'est normal
que ça arrive on a été injuste avec les
Russes et l'autre qui disent non surtout
voilà c'est la rue qui met on peut dire
les deux on peut dire qu'on a fait des
erreurs à l'égard de la Russie et que ce
que fait la Russie aujourd'hui tu aimes
y acceptable je viens je vois pas
pourquoi on ne serait pas capable de
mener cette réflexion des deux fronts
alors ce qui se passe c'est une guerre
qui pourrait durer longtemps et surtout
qu'il va avoir des conséquences
terribles Poutine a fait une erreur
majeure avant la guerre il a rétabli ses
positions partout au Proche-Orient il
est il parle avec Israël avec le Hama
c'est avec l'Iran avec les Saoudiens
avec le Qatar avec les émiratis son
allié syrien commence à être réintroduit
dans la famille il a une croissance qui
est assez bonne le chômage 6%, il
commence à être présent en Afrique etc
il a tout gâché il a tout gâché parce
que là quand même il va payer assez cher
et son rôle dans l'histoire Poutine
jusqu'ici pouvait dire voyez dans quel
état était le pays lorsque j'ai pris le
pouvoir vous voyez où il est maintenant
et effectivement on peut pas ne pas se
rappeler dans un état dans lesquels
était la Russie où il y estin un PIB
réduit de 50% en 9 ans il y a d'autres
pays qui ont les solutions plus
qu'autoritaires que celles de Poutine
avec une telle réduction du PIB
des gens partout des gens qui
n'arrivaient plus à vivre ça puis un
pays humilié donc mais Poutine peut dire
j'ai relevé le pays mais là il a gâché
cela par une erreur magistrale d'analyse
et c'est pas parce qu'il est fou comme
les américains font une erreur
magistrale d'analyse quand ils font la
baie des cochons ou quand ils augmentent
leur présence au Vietnam ou quand les
soviétique envahissent à Dean c'est
parfois pas être fou pour faire des
analyses faut juste avoir trop confiance
en soi ne pas écouter plusieurs voix et
ça revient un peu à ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure donc il surestime la
force russe et sous-estime la force de
l'Ukraine il sous-estime la réaction
occidentale et les trois réunis font que
il n'aura pas les bénéfices et en plus
il voulait envahir complètement
l'Ukraine avec 200000 hommes lorsque
l'ours a envahi la Tchécoslovaquie pour
changer le régime en 68 ils ont envoyé
500 000 mecs donc c'est pas que il faut
un type pour 25 habitants dans chaque
est dangereux surtout que ils a été pas
armé alors que les Ukrainiens le sont
donc c'était quand même plus facile donc
ce sur quoi va déboucher cette guerre
malheureusement
par rapport au projet français
d'autonomie européenne c'est mort c'est
la mort cérébrale parce que là les on
voit quand même le côté irrationnel en
réalité ce que les Russes ont montré
c'est que leur armée n'était pas si
puissante et qu'en réalité je vois pas
en quoi il est indispensable d'augmenter
autant nos dépenses militaires pour
faire face à une armée qui n'est pas
capable de mettre au pas l'armée
du diable et contrairement aux pluies de
bombe américaine qui a eu en Irak et
ensuite ils ont envoyé les GI Poutine
n'a pas fait ça non pas il a pas aplati
l'Ukraine et ensuite envoyer ces boys
ils ont d'abord envoyé leur boys c'est
vrai et parce qu'il a parce qu'il
pensait qu'en trois jours il arrivait à
keV qu'il changeait le régime et que
c'était mort mais ceci étant aujourd'hui
encore les services américains se
demandent pourquoi ils ne bombarde pas
plus massivement ils ont bomb
mais il y a d'autres endroits parce
qu'ils peuvent quand même pas détruire
qui est ils peuvent pas bon mais en tous
les cas le on voit bien quand même que
l'armée russe n'est pas aussi formidable
que cela mais beaucoup de conscrit des
jeunes appeler et puis au niveau dépense
militaires de 60 milliards de dollars
par an auparavant donc bon et donc on va
quand même tous augmenter nos dépenses
militaires et on va acheter les armes
aux États-Unis et l'OTAN qui était en
état de mort cérébrale selon Macron en
novembre 2019 c'est aujourd'hui le seul
jeu en ville tous les pays la Suède la
Finlande qui était des pays neutres vont
rejoindre l'OTAN tous les pays européens
disent oulala heureusement que les
Américains sont là pour nous protéger
d'une menace russe qui est effrayante
mais les pays européens de l'OTAN les
pays européens de l'OTAN
aujourd'hui un niveau de dépenses
militaire de 250 milliards de dollars
donc pour se protéger d'un pays quand on
les pense 60 ça devrait suffire
normalement mais on va augmenter il y a
une sorte d'irrationnité et si vous
dites aujourd'hui mais non mais vous
passez pour un mec qui est pas dans son
état normal qui anaïf qui a le
kimoscoutait etc et donc là jamais
l'OTAN n'a été aussi puissant
qu'aujourd'hui jamais autant n'a été
aussi unique aujourd'hui oublier les
débattre de Kaboul parce que si on
rembobine le film en septembre qu'est-ce
qui se passe tout le monde se dit bon
bah ok la crédibilité stratégique
américaine on a vu ce qu'elle valait
il signe un accord bâclé avec les
talibans et ils partent tous sans
éteindre la lumière et sans prévenir
leurs alliés y compris ceux qui ont les
troupes sur place donc ça a écrit un
choc profond y compris chez les plus
proches de les Etats-Unis et ça c'est
oublié et donc là de façon durable les
États-Unis ont
réétabli un impérium doux Pacifique pas
par la contrainte par la volonté des
autres à la demande des autres et jamais
l'influence américaine en Europe n'aura
été aussi forte parce que même du temps
qui Singère lui-même parlait des
malentendus transatlantiques voilà il y
en a pas donc Poutine là-dessus il a
vraiment fait l'inverse de ce qu'il
voulait faire l'Ukraine et l'identité
nationale ukrainienne c'est forgé contre
la Russie pour un long temps
l'OTAN n'a jamais été aussi soudé et
aussi antirrus et que pour la France qui
depuis de Gaulle et gérer depuis de
Gaulle y compris pendant la conduite de
la Seconde Guerre mondiale de Gaulle
avait déjà des relations
poussées avec Cyrus parce qu'il dit
voyez une façon déjà d'augmenter les
mars ces marges de manœuvre parce que
Roosevelt pouvait pas le saquer et
Churchill ne lui laissait pas toujours
toutes les libertés il disait qu'il
avait pas le choix et que la coopération
en Europe de la Russie bah là
aujourd'hui on pourra plus on pourra
plus c'est ensuite il a maintenu il a
continué quand il était au pouvoir la
vie de coachèvre en 60 sa visite en
Russie dans l'Union soviétique et lui
parler de la Russie d'ailleurs de Gaulle
il parlait de la Russie pas de l'Union
soviétique et puis ensuite Mitterrand a
continué etc mais là donc les ponts avec
la Russie une coopération politique avec
la Russie qui ne soit pas
agréée par les autres pays de l'OTAN
alors que jusqu'ici la France la France
ou à Laval la famille Atlantique la
famille Atlantique alors que jusqu'ici
la France était libre dans ses relations
avec Moscou Moscou dans soviétique ou
Moscou Russie ça c'est terminé pour un
bout de temps donc en fait on marche de
manœuvre cette guerre va beaucoup
réduire les marges de manœuvre de la
France
donc d'après d'après notre petit
tabouret on a vu les Russes se préparer
de longue date
établir des stratégies et des
contre-mesures en prévision de
Swift il travaillait dessus bien avant
les contre mesures sur le pétrole il
travaille bien avant dessus le rouble il
travaille bien avant dessus leur
armement il travaille bien avant avant
leur nouvelle technologie d'armement
leur super Messier bien avant
ils sont préparés donc la rancœur ou
l'agressivité était préparée
nous on n'a pas vu venir grand-chose
l'Europe l'Occident
là c'est parti pour durer
Biden demande plus de 30 milliards pour
l'Ukraine
c'est un pays corrompu c'est pas grave
ça va pas arriver dans les poches de
tout le monde c'est un peu comme les
armes on en voit beaucoup d'armes là-bas
mais ça va faire comme tête avec le
Kosovo on va les retrouver un peu chez
nous non
il y a des risques et enfin il faut
qu'on soit solidaire de l'Ukraine mais
si le PIB de l'Ukraine par habitant
était inférieur en 2021 ce qui était en
91 c'est pas de la faute de Poutine
donc oui il va falloir équiper notre
police c'est bien parce que le
lance-roquette antichard ça va faire du
plus bel effet sur les camions de
transport de fond revenons revenons à
nos moutons donc les Russes se sont
préparés on voit que leur dispositif
pour contrer les mesures occidentales
les sanctions occidentales ça a l'air de
fonctionner quand même il souffre quand
même un peu enfin moins que ce qu'on
pense il souffre mais ils sont très liés
non oui surtout c'est que les sanctions
elles sont pas internationales elles
sont occidentales c'est ça le
quand on entend parler de la communauté
internationale c'est très souvent la
communauté occidentale et donc dire que
des gens 2014 j'ai fait des bons ils ont
ah la communauté internationale a
sanctionné la Russie mais non Poutine
est allé au sommet des BRICS
au Brésil où il était très bien reçu par
tout le monde donc
regardez ce que font là ce que font etc
donc l'Occident les sanctions
effectivement
si le monde entier avait sanctionné la
Russie elle pourrait pas tenir très
longtemps
mais comme il n'y a que l'Occident qui
la sanctionne ça la gêne mais c'est on
peut vivre avec une jeune
surtout que en plus la crise augmente le
prix du pétrole et comme et c'est un
échec de Poutine 75% des recettes
d'exportation de la Russie viennent
toujours du gaz du pétrole il a pas su
diversifier l'économie de la Russie
parce que corruption etc mais donc là en
fait il avait bâti un budget sur un
baril à 40 dollars il a des marges
je crois que c'était 50 55
donc il peut faire des rabais une petite
digression
nos soviétologues de 90 qui sont
toujours pas tentés toujours en place
toujours ça vous fait pas penser à
la même faune d'expatrie qu'on croit
souvent à l'étranger qui se regroupe
tous entre expat dans les bars expats
dans les réunions d'expat ils font leur
lessive entre expat il bafouille trois
mots mais ils ont jamais été tapé la
news chez l'habitant comme on dit chez
nous ça vous fait pas penser à ça
c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont une vision mais
en fait ils connaissent pas du tout la
mentalité pays l'âme
vous avez deux sortes de soviétola ou de
russels maintenant vous avez des gens
déjà ils sont pas d'accord entre eux
donc en fait ils s'opposent de façon
très vive entre ceux
entre ceux qui pour faire court parce
que c'est caricatural mais certains
disent bon quand même
on s'est gouré avec la Russie on l'a
trop euh isolé on n'a pas fait le
nécessaire pour l'intégrer notre propre
démon voilà voilà on a on a créé nos
propres démons effectivement ça a bien
faire ça bon et d'autres qui disent mais
dès le départ c'est un démon
vous avez des gens qui vous disent mais
dès 2000 il y avait
Poutine portait la guerre comme la nuit
porte l'orage donc dès le départ il
était comme ça
quand même les journalistes qui tombent
de la fenêtre d'autres qui sont un peu
empoisonnés
alors non mais son autoritariste sa
répression sa brutalité y compris entre
Tchétchénie était très largement
documentée mais au début il veut se
rapprocher de l'Occident puis après il
estime qu'il a pas obtenu ce qu'il
voulait qu'on l'a traité comme un type
de seconde classe comme un pays de
seconde classe etc donc je vais faire
avec un Russe et avec personne parce que
ça coûte cher toujours le respect de
tolérer quand même le respect quand même
on continue à courber les Chine et avec
le sourire le respect ça se gagne quand
même c'est c'est une façon de et donc en
fait ce que vous appelez les
soviétologues les spécialistes
aujourd'hui de la Russie il y en a
vraiment de toutes sortes
hier en fait des gens qui s'auto
programme spécifiques de la Russie sans
y avoir jamais mis les pieds mais ils
ont lu des bouquins sur la Russie et ils
peuvent dire que vous dites un [__]
donc ils sont qualifiés de spécialistes
de la Russie donc d'autres qui font des
séjours prolongés
parce qu'ils connaissent sa société
c'est leur sujet d'études où ils ont
vécu ils se sont fait des amis etc et
donc bah ils ont donc il y a spécialiste
et spécialiste mais y compris parmi les
vrais spécialistes ceux qui parlent la
langue peuvent lire le Russe peuvent et
ben il y a effectivement cette division
entre disons les faucons et les colons
même si j'aime pas enfin dit en contre
les partisans du Ning dur et ceux d'une
ligne de dialogue cette division existe
parmi ceux que l'on peut qualifier
d'ayant une véritable connaissance de la
Russie donc en fait on peut avoir une
véritable connaissance de la Russie et
avoir deux opinions
parfaitement différente c'est pas
uniquement
le mec qui a lu trois bouquins sur la
Russie et qui a envie de taper sur
Poutine parce que ça fait plaisir aux
Américains qui
il n'y a pas que ça quoi il y a des
vrais spécialistes et certains alors
certains ont aussi des il y en a qui ont
qui ont vécu en Russie qui ont une
détestation personnelle de Poutine pour
des raisons très diverses dont certains
sont tout à fait légitimes donc il y a
aussi des gens qui confondent le pays et
son leader mais où leur expérience
personnelle ou leur expérience
personnelle voilà on peut pas bon à ça
c'est vrai aussi bon vous avez ça dans
le petit circuit
les gens résident des fois moins la
flatterie qu'elle la torture donc si
vous êtes bien reçu quelque part pensez
que le pays est formidable et si vous
avez une déconvenue que le café pas
assez chaud etc vous avez pensé que
c'est un pays de merde donc il y a aussi
ce genre de prisme un peu qui peut des
fois venir déformer c'est pas grand
chose mais ça arrive parfois aussi
revenons à la psychiatrisation de
Poutine par par certains soviologues
d'ailleurs
quand on regarde les fondamentaux de
l'économie russe de sa démographie de
l'état de sépuits de pétrole de l'état
de ce qui se passe autour de chez elle
est-ce que vous pensez pas que le fait
qu'il tape maintenant c'était parce
qu'il pouvait encore se le permettre
il a certainement pensé qu'il avait une
fenêtre d'opportunité qui allait se
refermer et il a certainement pensé que
la l'Ukraine allait rentrer dans l'OTAN
et que c'était maintenant qu'il fallait
taper
est-ce qu'il pense que son pays va vers
le déclin
en fait si c'est le cas qui au pouvoir
depuis 20 ans et à qui doit-il en faire
le reproche est-ce que si je me permets
de couper est-ce que son pays
et son oligarchie est assise sur les
matières premières nécessaires à la
nucléarisation du monde en termes de
centrale nucléaire de crayon de
combustible de ce qu'on met dans les
crayons combustibles des gaines de
crayon de combustible de pétrole de
terre rare et j'en passais les meilleurs
et est-ce qu'il se sent pas un petit peu
comme
le gardien qui se fait entourer son
coffre par des gens qui ont faim il y a
ça c'est que avec un réchauffement
climatique qui s'énerve les réfugiés
c'est vrai que la rente pétrolière
pétrolière crée de la corruption
et créer des mauvaises habitudes et elle
est quand même
moi ce qui me frappe c'est que les
Russes ont une école de mathématiciens
formidables des savants formidables où
sont les géants digitaux russes
Poutine lui-même a dit que celui qui
maîtriserait l'intelligence artificielle
de Mireille le monde mais où sont les
investissements de la Russie
dans les dans l'intelligence
artificielle ils sont vachement à labour
là-dessus donc parce que en fait comme
ils sont assis sur une rente quand vous
êtes rentier vous innovez pas je veux
dire ce qui est vrai pour la veuve de
Carpentras et aussi vrai pour le
dirigeant de la Russie donc bon et là
effectivement mais je pense sur je pense
surtout que c'est pas tellement par
rapport à l'état de parce que si
vraiment il y avait un état que bientôt
soucier va se terminer il aurait mis en
oeuvre des réformes pour éviter ça s'il
tient quand même beaucoup à sa place
dans l'histoire
là il est en train de l'attacher
donc je pense qu'il est plutôt le
sentiment que
d'une part l'Ukraine va rentrer dans
l'OTAN et en fait l'Ukraine n'allait pas
rentrer dans le temps mais l'OTAN était
déjà dans l'Ukraine depuis longtemps
de formation par les armements l'OTAN
forme l'armée ukrainienne depuis 2014
ils les ont préparé pourquoi l'armée
ukrainienne a mieux résister que prévu à
l'armée russe c'est que elle a été
préparée par l'OTAN depuis 2014 et qui a
un patriotisme et on se bat toujours
mieux quand on défend son territoire
quand on défend sa patrie que quand on
attaque celle de l'autre ça c'est une
leçon donc
il a eu ça et puis aussi on dit que
Poutine ne comprend que les rapports de
force mais enfin tout le monde ne
comprend que les rapports de force c'est
jamais entendu une phrase plus stupide
que celle-là c'est l'ordre mélien ben
oui mais est-ce que je veux dire Johnson
Macron Biden Trump Merkel scholls tout
le monde tous les dirigeants ne
comprennent que le rapport de force
c'est la vie internationale elle est une
vie fait de rapport de force et donc
Poutine a pensé vraiment que décidément
on l'écoutait pas etc et là où il a fait
une terrineur c'est que il commençait à
obtenir des choses sa conférence sur la
sécurité en Europe qui réclame depuis
longtemps et on a même pas répondu à ses
demandes et que Gorbatchev aussi avait
demandé que Mitterrand avait demandé
s'il était encore et bien il aurait pu
l'obtenir et donc là il a il a vraiment
tout foutu en l'air mais aussi pendant
très longtemps il a demandé gentiment et
on lui a rien d'accordé
les pauses ukrainien il faut qu'il
s'attendent à quoi à une un
ukrainistant
au sein de l'Europe c'était on va
embourber les Russes comme on a fait en
Afghanistan
il faut s'attendre à quoi les
Ukrainiens il faut faut leur dire
oublier de rentrer dans le pays pour les
deux prochaines années non il commence à
rentrer
ça et là ceux qui s'occupent de l'aide
humanitaire à l'Ukraine estime que ça
marche bien que c'est bien géré y
compris par les qualities locales
ukrainiennes faut envoyer beaucoup de
temps parce que les immeubles sont
détruits mais discriminiens qui rentrent
chez eux dans les villes dont l'armée
russe est partie mais là faut beaucoup
de temps c'est ça qui manque pour
l'instant etc donc en fait ça dépend à
la fois de ce que veulent les ukrainiens
et de ce que leur donneront les
Américains
que va les Ukrainiens est-ce qu'ils
veulent reprendre toutes les terres que
la Russie leur appliquée bien entendu
oui mais depuis 2014 depuis 2022
j'ai interrogé un député ukrainien à un
débat dimanche dernier il m'a dit oui il
faut qu'on récupère tout mais mais pour
la Crimée on peut négocier donc grosso
modo parce que faut pas aussi oublier
que même si l'Ukraine n'est pas un pays
nazi il y a une extrême droite en
Ukraine qui a empêché les années ski
d'aller plus loin dans leur approchement
avec la Russie et qui le menaçait s'il
se rapproche un peu trop de la Russie
donc il y a des gens qui veulent dire
non non on aura la paix avec les Russes
y compris en Ukraine que le jour où on
aura libéré de nouveau la Crimée et le
bombasse disons les républiques
autoproclamés du Dombas de données ce
qui est de Lougansk donc si vous le
récupérer ça ça va être dur est-ce
qu'ils veulent récupérer toutes les tous
les territoires que Poutine et la Russie
ont conquis depuis le 24 février
mais ça je veux dire ça veut dire que
Poutine a fait la guerre pour rien
et qui rentre enfin voilà qu'il va dire
aux Russes oh là là on a pris une
déculottée et tout ça pour rien et tout
ce que vous allez souffrir etc pour rien
donc c'est quand même un peu gênant pour
lui et c'est là où je viens jusqu'où
voudront avoir aller les ingrédients en
termes de reconquête de ce qu'ils ont
perdu et jusqu'où les Américains
accepteront de les aider pour cette
reconquête est-ce qu'un jour les
Américains est-ce que pour l'instant les
Américains disent regardez un peu comme
un boulanger un pâtissier avec des
gamins qui disent écoutez la pâtisserie
ouverte vous vous servez tout ce que
vous voulez c'est gratos allez-y bon si
les Américains disent toutes les
Matelles que vous voulez Ukrainiens on
vous les donnera les Ukrainiens vont
vouloir aller jusqu'au bout est-ce que
les gens
c'est du business
alors lorsque la France a fourni 4 ou 6
ou 5 je sais plus Super Étendard à
l'Irak en 80 82 dans sa guerre contre
l'Iran et que l'Irak tapait les
terminaux pétrolières l'irania la France
est obligérante et ils ont fait des
attentats ils ont tué un ambassadeur etc
alors c'est vrai que les avions français
piloter par des Irakiens à les taper en
territoire iranien
ça effectivement que peut-être la Chine
fait la guerre par proxy avec la Russie
non parce qu'il n'aide pas militairement
la Russie qui n'ont pas envie de l'aider
que les chinois sont aussi fâchés de ce
qu'on fait pour les Chinois c'est
perturbant tout ça et surtout il y a
beaucoup de choses qui gênent les
Chinois c'est que ils pensent que
naturellement ils vont devenir la
première puissance mondiale donc c'est
donc c'est pas la peine de faire des
guerres ça va venir tout seul donc quand
on fait une guerre on emmerde le monde
en plus là les chinois ils payent plus
cher de trucs qu'ils apportent beaucoup
les produits alimentaires parce que la
Chine c'est 8% des surfaces cultivables
du monde 22% de la population donc un
déficit et l'énergie
du pognon bah oui mais moi parce que
quand même le covid les un petit peu
affaibli surtout maintenant quel
confinement et que la légitimité du
Parti communiste chinois c'est pas le
petit livre rouge de Mao ou les huit
tomes de capital c'est le taux de
croissance de l'économie donc ce qui
vient baisser le taux de croissance
économie vient embêter le Parti
communiste chinois et puis surtout c'est
que
l'OTAN resserré l'OTAN le discours de
byder en juin 2021 Biden vient en Europe
et il dit à tout le monde il faut qu'on
fasse G7 sommet du G7 sommet de l'OTAN
donc sommet occidentaux et il y a tout
le monde par rapport à l'axe des pays
autoritaires il faut faire une grande
coalition des démocraties
occidentale bien sûr les pays européens
la France a mal disait non enfin ça
marche pas pour longtemps la Chine n'est
pas dans l'Atlantique Nord là vous allez
voir qu'au prochain sommet de l'OTAN
la machine sera dans chaque ligne parce
que le discours de Biden de dire que il
faut faire une grande coalition des
démocraties contre l'axe des pays
autoritaire et bien ressort beaucoup
plus nettement après la guerre que la
Russie on sait contre l'Ukraine donc ça
n'est pas tellement les Chinois tout
cela donc les chinois sont pas très
contents de ce qu'on fait les Russes
mais
il ne les laisseront pas tomber
parce que comme la Corée du Nord mais la
Russie est plus présentable parce que si
la Russie s'écroule c'est une victoire
des occidentaux que les Chinois n'ont
aucune envie de laisser aux Occidentaux
donc ils ne font pas la guerre à proxy
avec les Russes il leur fournissent pas
le matériel militaire il leur permet de
tourner les sanctions oui ça d'accord
parce que ils ont pas prise donc en fait
bon et mais il préférait que tout ça
s'arrête quoi
c'est c'est contraire leurs intérêts
parce qu'en fait c'est aussi quel est le
grand gagnant de cette guerre qui n'a
pas décidé c'est les États-Unis par
rapport à l'OTAN par rapport les pays
européens vont plus acheter du gas pas
cher qui vient de Russie on va acheter
du gaz plus cher qui vient des
États-Unis
pourquoi oui parce que parce que ce que
vous êtes dire c'est qu'on va acheter
des armes aux Américains qu'on va
acheter l'orgasme on va l'acheter plus
cher contrat de fidélisation à l'autre
temps et oui mais en plus en payant plus
cher c'est qu'on va payer plus cher on
va dire merci ce qui est normal
une petite tape sur la tête comme ça
donc effectivement les Européens sont
les grands perdants de enfin l'Ukraine
bien sûr mais l'Ukraine dès que la
guerre sera finie elle pourra être
construite le crin est devenu un pays
martyre on a oublié tous les reproches
qu'on faisait l'Ukraine
la corruption la gestion de ce pays
tout enfin vraiment une fois encore
c'était
comment la prostitution des réseaux de
prostitution aussi ça ça n'a jamais gêné
personne je crois en termes de relations
internationales ni en termes de
condamnation mais bon il y a de la mafia
etc mais bon mais non mais surtout c'est
que une fois encore un pays dont le PIB
par habitant est inférieur 30 ans plus
tard son indépendance parce qu'en fait
il y a quand même quelque chose qui
unissait les oligarques en Ukraine qui
soit pro russe ou pro-occidentaux poyou
bah voilà qui s'embêtait plein les
poches au détriment du peuple ukrainien
peuple ukrainien qui a souffert il y a
quand même rendons des 2 millions
d'habitants de la Crimée qui ont été
annexés par la Russie il y a quand même
7 millions d'Ukrainiens qui ont quitté
le pays par manque de perspectives parce
que faire des études les gens étaient
brillants etc mais ça ne bougeait pas
sur des boulots donc
comme les pauvres libanais voilà voilà
revenons revenons à l'ukri listant donc
l'OTAN va
arroser de super armement
les Russes vont s'embourber
on va faire comme en 14 c'est encore les
femmes les enfants les personnes âgées
qui vont encore morfler
dans tout ça l'Europe a fait quoi elle
fait l'Europe de la défense elle essaie
de se faire une armée elle essaie de
faire quoi elle continue le côté BD nous
on protège la démocratie de le désert
ou qu'est-ce qu'on devrait faire alors
pour revenir déjà au point de départ sur
l'ukrainistant
soit russe et ukrainien trouve un accord
qui permet à chacun de sauver la face
mais pour ça faut beaucoup de
d'intelligence et surtout beaucoup
de pas céder à l'émotion et d'affronter
l'opinion etc or pour zelinsky qui est
devenu une éco-mondiale qui peut se
permettre de dire au président allemand
je veux pas que tu viennes chez moi
alors qu'ils demandent l'aide à
l'Allemagne c'est quand même fort de
café quand même bon le la Rebuffat
qu'ils ont fait aux Allemands que ce
pays qui demande l'aide des pays
européens dit au président un pays
fédérale allemande non non tu es trop
proche des russe tu ne veux pas que tu
viennes chez moi alors que bon c'est
quand même bon bref
les Luxembourg ça passe
une petite question de proximité et il
peut il aura du mal à dire j'accepte
d'avoir perdu Mario Paul
accepte qu'il y a une bande territoriale
entre le don-basse et la Crimée qui soit
russe et Poutine de son côté peut pas
dire voilà tout ce que j'ai gagné depuis
le 24 février j'ai rendu parce que on
n'est pas et donc c'est ça qui va être
difficile donc moi c'est terminé donc on
a pas un accord sur cet accord ça risque
de durer longtemps ce mal se terminait
ou mal se terminer s'il y a un
élargissement
protège un peu les menaces à peine
déguisées de frappe nucléaire tactique
stratégique elle n'apporterait rien d'un
point de vue militaire enfin le
détruirait tout mais on peut tout
détruire sur un périmètre sans armes du
clerc tactique donc c'est je pense un
peu pour faire peur c'est la dissuasion
c'est la dissuasion disons offensive
c'est ne venez pas trop m'emmerder parce
que j'ai des armes nucléaires chacun
rappelle cela mais pour revenir à votre
question sur l'Europe dans un premier
temps l'Europe dit bon on va faire
effectivement on serait arme l'Allemagne
va dépenser 100 milliards
supplémentaires pour la défense en 5 ans
le budget militaire de la France c'est
40 milliards donc chaque année
l'Allemagne va l'Allemagne va arriver
bientôt à 60-70 milliards dépenses
militaires la France va monter aussi
mais l'Allemagne va dépenser plus que
nous donc c'est normal ils ont un PIB
plus important que l'autre donc faut
bien que ça se retrouve
alors après vous avez deux options
l'option optimiste
on serait arme et du coup on se dit ah
bah tiens finalement on est armés donc
finalement on peut se défendre ah bah
donc on va se défendre en tant que
européen mais je crois pas que ça soit
le scénario principal pourquoi parce que
les militaires allemands ils sont
biberonnés à l'OTAN si vous êtes
militairement vous faites pas carrière
dans la mundes verts vous faites
carrière c'est l'OTAN qui aurait fait
une carrière parce que
du fait de tout
ce soft power la famille voilà en fait
toutes les armées qui sont quand la
France est à réintégrer les organes
militaires intégrés de l'OTAN si Sarkozy
voilà
et on s'est dit mais c'est pas grave on
peut rester indépendant oui on peut
rester indépendance Sarkozy qui était
son petit surnom Sarkozy l'Américain
voilà il a fait campagne là-dessus il a
du pot il a décidé qu'en Obama était
président donc c'est pas ça aurait été
un autre président ça aurait été plus
difficile bon François Hollande qui a
protesté contre la réintégration de n'a
pas remis en cause lorsqu'il a été élu
président
mais en fait aujourd'hui il y a plus de
militaires français qui sont à l'été
majeurs de l'OTAN Kabala
et donc quand vous êtes vous circulez
comme ça ça infuse
[Musique]
on dit non non on y va tout de suite et
ça sera le résultat et en fait c'est pas
le cas et donc je crains quand même que
au bout du compte on est plutôt une
Europe pas beaucoup plus je dirais
tanisé avec des Américains qui ne font
encore apparaissent comme le seul
recours possible pour nous protéger
contre cette menace ruse qui à la fois
réelle militairement je sais pas la nier
mais en même temps une fois encore
quand on a du mal à aller jusqu'à keV on
n'est pas prêt d'arriver à Berlin
avec un petit missile Super Sonic ça
prend moins de temps oui leur propagande
leur propagande interne qui consiste à
montrer des vidéos de leur super missile
capable de frapper des capitales
européennes avec leur super bombinette
qui est capable de raser la France ou
l'Angleterre en un seul coup
c'est de la propagande intérieure c'est
un message extérieur c'est bon ils se
font plaisir oui c'est effectivement il
rassure leur population
c'est bon on est protégé et puis c'est
un rappel mais c'est la dissuasion a
toujours été ça c'est dire la dissuasion
il faut c'est pas la certitude de
parvenir à toucher votre cible c'est la
peur que l'autre a que vous puissiez le
faire
donc ils font un rappel de dire que eux
aussi ils ont des armes qui en trois
minutes peuvent arriver à Paris ou à
Londres
dans tout ça l'Afrique elle fait quoi
elle regarde elle essayait d'avoir l'eau
du robinet l'Afrique déjà dans tout ça
bah elle va payer plus cher de quoi
bouffer
ce qui va avoir les mêmes conséquences
pour les révolution arabe qu'on a connu
en 2008 voilà 11 pardon donc il y a il y
a quand même des pénuries alimentaires
qui sont quand même du perspective qui
sont quand même assez inquiétantes c'est
acté là
alors il paraît que là
en plus là les pays européens donnent
des plans de pommes de terre aux
Ukrainiens ça pousse plus vite que le
blé etc enfin pour nourrir
c'est pas ce qu'il y a de l'ami
source fiable oui tout à fait donc bon
voilà enfin faut essayer de trouver des
moyens mais enfin quand même et surtout
l'Afrique il y a semences éternel et
l'année 90 l'Afrique est mal parti c'est
René Dumont avait 1000 fois raison c'est
le continent sans espoir corruption le
sida le relais génocide rwandais les
guerres civile sergialeon Liberia et
patins et couffins donc vraiment et à
l'époque d'ailleurs
je vois les responsables politiques
français nouveau voulait pas aller en
Amérique vous voulez pas être associé au
vieux de la vieille qui partent en
Afrique et qui revenait des fois avec
des bagages plus chargés que ceux à qui
ils étaient partis avec lesquels ils
étaient partis et puis après l'année de
début du 21e siècle message d'espoir
plus de démocratie du développement 5%
au niveau global etc des sociétés
civiles qui se développent etc et
là la fin la fin enfin moins de conflits
etc la Libye a été une erreur tragique
c'était une erreur on a enlevé un
dictateur effectivement et certains qui
voulaient lancer les satellites et puis
arrêter le français construire un
barrage mais c'était pas possible qu'on
essaie un mec comme ça
les élections électorales alors rappelez
qu'à l'époque on a dit que la guerre
morale une guerre qui a été faite pour
la morale s'il y a pas d'intérêt pour
les petites filles voilà exactement
alors sauf que la guerre de Libye et
qu'est-ce qu'elle a comme inconvénient
bah l'état de la Libye déjà l'avantage
il y a plus qu'à DAFI alors oui mais le
prix à payer pour être débarrassé de
Kadhafi et quand même de même que on a
zigouillé Saddam Hussein mais les
Irakiens ont payé quand même plus cher
que avant et donc tout de suite vous
formalisez sur les détails le prix que
les Libyens ont payé quand même plutôt
cher le prix que les Africains ont payé
l'esclavage de tous les Africains qui
passaient par les billes ont été remises
et on oublie de dire que tous les pays
africains étaient contre l'intervention
ils écoutent pas mais non
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qui vole plus
toujours pour nous maintenant il s'est
contre l'argent parce que pensait qu'on
pouvait négocier le Kadhafi et lui
offrir un refuge etc ils étaient ils
voyaient bien jusqu'où ça allait on a
tué dans le Mali quand il a été
déstabilisé par cette intervention on a
tué le concept de responsabilité de
protéger qui était un peu une
alternative entre on fait la guerre où
on fait rien et surtout
plus on va revenir à la Russie
mettre des lèvres et président à
l'époque
Poutine et Premier ministre et son
pantin oui mais là il décide je mets de
l'élève voulait se rapprocher des
Occidentaux et si on refait un peu le
fil de l'histoire à l'époque en
2008-2009 2010 certains Poutine il va se
faire avoir
comme Chirac s'est fait avoir par
Belgian
va penser que finalement la place est
bonne et que il demanderait bien
deuxième mandat et mettre devait
commencer à occuper un espace mais de
l'élève veut se rapprocher des
Occidentaux et donc ils s'abstient sur
la résolution en 1973 qui permet
d'utiliser la force pour aller au départ
protégé la population de Benghazi
Poutine lui dit 973 1973 la résolution
de la résolution
et Poutine dit à medlev mais tu vas te
faire avoir par les Occidentaux comme
d'habitude tu faut que tu mettes ton
véto mais non non écoute là on a un coup
à jouer et puis on change la mission en
cours de route on passe de protéger la
population il faut buter Kadhafi parce
qu'on se dit que tant que calafiste va
pouvoir la population libyenne ne sera
pas protégée donc mes élèves du coup bah
voilà ses rêves d'accéder à la
présidence et Poutine lui en a voulu
mais d'élèves est apparu comme étant
faible parce que pro occidental etc et
on oublie une chose c'est la Syrie parce
que si la Russie a mis intensivement des
vétos sur toute la Syrie et la brosse
l'a dit a Fabius confus était ministre
tel quel que vous nous avez baisé sur la
Libye vous baiserez pas sur la Syrie
donc la Syrie le malheureux peuple
syrien paye les fracas de la guerre en
Irak et de l'intervention
occidentale en limite
bien sûr il paye
bien sûr il paye la répression
sanguine sanguinaire sauvage de Bachar
el-Assad mais
si on n'avait pas eu les épisodes
d'ibiens peut-être qu'on aurait pu avoir
non pas cette haine massive de la Russie
à Bachard qui lui a permis de rester au
pouvoir et de commettre qu'il réussisse
aussi de nombreux crimes de guerre
de l'Afrique oui alors la fin des tours
parce que
on a parlé en la fin des tours en
parlant de l'intervention en Libye donc
l'Afrique les Français sont fait botter
le cul
vous allez rentrer c'est terminé
maintenant on voit on voit du Wagner
russe un peu partout là-bas on voit du
chinois un peu partout là-bas il reste
encore un petit peu de l'américain mais
le Français
c'est terminé alors c'est pas terminé
mais c'est en récession
et il y a à la fois les évolutions
normales et d'autres qui nous sont dus
les évolutions normales c'est que on a
plus le monopole des relations avec
l'Afrique c'est que l'Afrique est
multi-courtisée par les Chinois les
Japonais les Russes etc bon et voilà
donc il y a plus le bon la bon la bonne
vieille rente monopolistique française
dans la fibre francophone mais il y a
des choses dont on est responsable
l'intervention au Libye on aurait pu
éviter effectivement
le fait
d'être associé
Macron fait le même temps et en même
temps on confie à chez MB et on va un
rapport sur l'Afrique donc quelqu'un qui
a intellectuel libre
d'expression qui critiquent la France
Afrique etc on fait un sommet avec la
qui s'épan sommet France Afrique avec
les jeunes et on va aux obsèques débit
et on soutient des régimes qui sont là
depuis 40 ans les régimes héréditaires
qui n'en présentent pas l'avenir et puis
aussi autre chose moi je
suis très sensible moi j'ai pas le
spectateur régional donc avant le covid
je me baladais à peu près une semaine
par mois à l'étranger en fonction des
invitations des colloques etc sur les
pas trop l'Océanie c'est loin mais à peu
près partout quoi je vois bien la perte
de prestige de la France
depuis le début du siècle après au début
du siècle on est champion du monde de
football alors là je dis je dis pas la
popularité de la France après la
victoire de l'équipe blackburner Chirac
et on a Chirac qui refuse
on est le pays
occidental le plus populaire parce que
c'est le pays qui est courageuse qui dit
les choses qui plaident pour les petits
etc
voilà mais tout ça ça compte beaucoup et
puis la tradition gaulienne Mitterrand
etc se souvenir aussi historique
après on a eu
mais surtout je dirais les débats parce
qu'en fait j'ai un débat avec une
candidate c'est dans l'air je lui dis
mais vous vendez pas compte que des fois
nos débats internes sont regardés à
l'étranger une candidate
sur la perte d'influence de la France
elle dit oui il faut réformer l'Agence
française pour le développement mais ça
suffit pas l'AFD
et en fait on est dans un monde
globalisé
nos obsessions sur l'islam elles sont
perçues à l'étranger les discours
d'exclusion sur les réfugiés les
discours racistes sur les Africains ils
sont perçus à l'étranger et puis là le
coup des Ukrainiens blond aux yeux bleus
qu'on accepte et que bon et pas etc donc
en fait nos débats internes
ou sur un débat télévisé des fois sur 6
personnes vous avez trois mecs qui sont
d'extrême droite et un quiz de gauche
mais qu'en fait illamophobe ça ça se
voit à l'étranger
et alors on est critiqué de façon par
les pays effectivement du Sud qui disent
bon bah en fait vous nous aimez pas les
visas etc donc les Africains maintenant
c'est plus facile d'aller aux États-Unis
qu'en France ils apprennent la langue
etc donc bon et
puis enfin l'obsession sur le voile
je viens ça tout ça tout ça vient sur le
voile je peux me faire avocat du diable
quand même dites en Bretagne est-ce que
vous voyez
en Bourgogne vous voyez un voile
intégral non alors
non non quand vous allez dans un pays
musulman ou quand vous allez sur un
une mosquée vos chaussures vous voyez la
tête quand il y a des femmes ainsi de
suite oui il y a pas de débat mais
l'affaire du mur qui dit pour quelques
personnes qui habitent en clinique
c'était une affaire il y avait juste en
2016 la conférence qui avait lieu juste
après c'est quoi un burkini c'est une
maillot de bain un peu intégral si j'ose
dire avec lequel certaines femmes
voulaient se baigner et qui était vu
comme une politique voilà alors c'est
vraiment ce que les gens qui disent le
complotisme et le pratiquent aussi
eux-mêmes là on voyait ça comme un
complot parce que les gens avaient un
vrai projet et que ces femmes étaient à
la pointe avancée des Frères musulmans
pour faire avancer la cause du burkini
en France c'est juste de là qui vous
laisse baigner comme ça bon
certaines avaient un projet mais une
demi-douzaine sur bon et donc en lors de
cette conférence
tous les anciens que je connaissais avec
qui je parlais me disait mais ouais dans
mon pays on se demande si rien à la
France et non seulement a été musulman
mais aussi dans les pays nordiques dans
les pays anglo-saxons je veux dire le
guardiame le New York Times se pose des
questions sur
l'attitude que l'on a par rapport à
l'Islam
et donc ça effectivement
et ben Chirac était très ouvert aux
cultures étrangères et Mitterrand aussi
etc bon de Gaulle a émis fin à la guerre
d'Algérie donc en fait nos débats
internes qui sont beaucoup quand même
des débats un peu d'exclusion par
rapport à l'autre par rapport au
réfugiés et une fois encore par rapport
à l'islam etc sont perçus et font que on
est moins apprécié qu'on était
auparavant ça c'est clair dans un monde
globalisé nos débats on sait ce qu'on
dit sur les autres et ce que les
étrangers étant de ce qui est dit en
France n'est pas toujours très
appétissant pour eux j'ouvre encore une
parenthèse vous parliez de la Libye
cette étincelante victoire pour la
démocratie et vous parlez de l'Irak qui
est aussi une étincelante victoire pour
la démocratie qui n'a pas coûté
grand-chose en terme d'armement du radio
ma pauvrerie de mutilation d'enfants
d'école bombarder Jean passer des
meilleurs
c'était échec tous les gens qui ont
participé à cette échelle à ses échecs
pourquoi ils sont pas virés
Manu military alors
les gens qui ont participé à la Libye
ou pas bon effectivement
ce qu'on a dit là Biden demande à ce que
Poutine soit déférée devant la Cour
[__] il le mériterait il mériterait
non papa
mais ils n'ont pas signé le traité
et si Poutine doit aller devant la Cour
Pénale George Bush et Tony Blair aussi
fils
père non regardez la guerre du Golf de
90 n'a pas eu les conséquences
catastrophiques de la guerre d'Irak de
2003 parce que mais là aussi le grand
tournant par rapport à Moscou Gorbatchev
accepte de voter la résolution pour la
première fois l'ONU fonctionne tel qu'on
l'avait prévu il y a un pays qui a
commis un acte très grave en termes de
violation de droit international on a le
droit d'employer la force pour le
sanctionner s'il n'a pas réparé
accepte de l'achat d'un allié
salam Hussein était son allié était allé
dur s'il accepte de lâcher au nom
d'un avenir
dans lequel l'ONU résoudrait les
questions de sécurité Jean je bouche
proclame le père le nouvel ordre mondial
et juste après et bah on va dire vive le
monde du nippolaire et en juillet
91 Gorbatchev vient devant le G7
demandez une aide supplémentaire au pays
du G7 pour réussir la péristorica collé
Mitterrand sont d'accord John Major et
George Bush disent non parce qu'il se
disent bah on a tout obtenu on a obtenu
avec une vision allemande la retraite
d'Afghanistan etc puis il y a le signe
qui va arriver ça sera mieux
et Gorbatchev leur dit messieurs c'est
la dernière fois que vous voyez comme
président l'Union soviétique un mois
après tentative de coup d'état
échec total il estime ramasse tes
morceaux dissolution de l'URSS et il y a
cette illusion d'un monde unipolaire
dans lequel les États-Unis pourraient
faire ce qu'ils veulent mais c'est aussi
ça qui a amen au pouvoir un Poutine
absolument raide et assoiffé de revanche
si les rockeurs
on parlait de tempête géopolitique je
vais vous dresser un petit peu l'état
des lieux
réchauffement climatique incontrôlable
une économie qui n'est pas prête à
comprendre ce qu'est le réchauffement
climatique parce que basé sur la
transformation de ressources et c'est
pas le tout
écologiste qui vont nous faire
comprendre que ça va changer
donc réchauffement climatique
problématique pour les récoltes pour la
nourriture donc pour les gens des
migrants qui vont être obligés de bouger
parce que zone invivable dû aux
températures et autour d'humidité
un système financier qui est en train de
marcher avec des cannes des
déambulateurs d'aide de banque centrale
des banques centrales qui sont
transformées en bas de banque ou ça
concentre tout ce qui devrait pas être
concentré
qu'est-ce que j'ai oublié d'autres on a
la pandémie tension chez une Taïwan
[Musique]
Éthiopie etc enfin bon oui donc zone
problématique
est-ce que ça va pas se terminer du
chacun son cul et Dieu pour tous
en gros on va avoir un bon gros rythme
rideau de fer de Mamie en plein milieu
de l'Europe les Russes qui vont rester
assis sur leur tas de ressources avec
leurs copains chinois et nous l'Europe
on va gentiment dépérir au soleil avec
les États-Unis qui nous disent c'est
bien les gars continuez
en tous les cas si on fait pas si
l'Europe ne comprend pas il y avait des
avantages en Europe c'est le
multilatéralisme
on est d'accord sur rien c'est ça
c'est que l'Europe est une construction
multilatérale donc c'est quand même son
ADN alors parfois ça tarde à déboucher
sur un accord mais quand même des fois
on en trouve donc l'Europe quand même et
certains pays européens plus que
d'autres ont à la fois une mémoire
historique de la puissance et en même
temps ont perdu l'illusion de vouloir
dominer le monde l'Europe ne veut pas
dominer le monde la Russie veut dominer
son étranger proche les amis veulent
dominer le monde la Chine veut quand
même avoir l'Asie et la mère de Chine
sous sa coupe et puis on verra plus tard
pour aller plus loin l'Europe a été
vacciné
contre les excès de la puissance donc il
y a quand même un modèle européen qui
et soyez européen il vous rigolez mais
le sommeil européen regardez les
réfugiés syriens ils veulent pas aller
en Arabie Saoudite
pas de façon oui enfin ils vont en
Europe disons que l'Europe est
attractive pour l'extérieur elle est
parfois
effectivement elle a un peu ceux qui
sont dedans mais ceux qui sont à
l'extérieur les Balkans les Georgiens
les Ukrainiens ou les dents africains
pour les accords d'association ou les
citoyens veulent venir donc si vous
voulez je suis assez critique sur
l'Europe notamment sur la docilité
qu'elle a à l'égard les Etats-Unis par
tradition stratégique par dépendance en
fait il y a une dépendance stratégique
européenne à gazelle historique docile
c'est pas le bon mot je pense
soumission irait mieux la docilité c'est
quand même déjà pas mal parce que quand
même déjà pas mal
et il y a quand même des fois où on se
rebelle quand même bon pas bon mais mais
il y a quand même des choses que
l'Europe peut faire qui sont pas mal
par rapport au climat l'Europe est quand
même plutôt en pointe par rapport aux
autres blocs de civilisation nous on
exporte mieux notre non non comment on
formule ça nous on décentralise mieux
notre pollution ailleurs c'est ça non on
est quand même l'Europe fondit l'Europe
est quand même le premier fournisseur
d'aide multilatérale au développement et
qui concerne également la lutte contre
un changement climatique l'Europe quand
même a été un peu en pointe par rapport
à la réduction des gaz à effet de serre
etc donc il faut rendre justice il y a
des choses qui sont très critiquables à
bureaucratie blabla des fois le fait
d'oublier cela je pense que
l'élargissement est trop rapide
et qu'on aurait mieux fait de faire une
robe à cercle concentrique différent etc
mais il y a quand même des choses plutôt
pas mal du côté européen sauf que voilà
je voulais en revenir là c'est qu'on est
pour les raisons historique dépendante
des États-Unis sur le plan stratégique
et la dépendance c'est très difficile
d'en sortir quelle qu'elle soit et donc
on a cette culture de la dépendance à
l'égard des États-Unis qui nous empêche
d'être autonome et l'autonomie
stratégique européenne n'est pas être
anti-américain c'est être autonome c'est
ne pas être dépendant mais ça
n'achètent pas ça
les détenus par qui
le dette de France de notre tête d'État
est-ce qu'il y a des fonds vautours qui
pourraient nous faire taire nos
politiciens s'ils deviennent trop
turbulents alors
pour savoir le qui
détient la dette mais en même temps ce
que l'on peut craindre c'est une
remontée des taux qui la rendent moins
indolore qu'elle ne l'est aujourd'hui
question internet alors je commence par
la question qui n'a rien à voir est-ce
que Pascal a prévu de voir le match de
Ligue des Champions ce soir
donc question sérieuse que fait la
première question ouais non si ça avait
été un match de rugby peut-être mais là
question sérieuse ce que font les
sérieux le foot la géopolitique du sport
on va traiter ce sujet là on va bien
rigoler d'ailleurs question que font les
USA avec
hocus en CUS
ils font ce grand mur en chinois ils
font le mur dans l'eau en fait donc ils
veulent contenir la Chine et il faut ce
qu'on appelle les prophéties
autorisateurs vous désignez un pays
comme un ennemi et à force il devient
c'est ça ma grande crainte donc hocus
c'est
Australie et Royaume-Uni États-Unis
c'est une alliance
l'Australie avait trois ou quatre fois
plus de commerce avec la Chine qu'avec
les États-Unis
en plus
et là en fait il s'agit leur dit non non
vous venez etc et donc en fait
qu'est-ce qui obsède
pour les quel est l'obsession américaine
de la Chine c'est pas les droits de
l'homme ça c'est des conneries
que ça non mais j'ai bien sûr la Chine
ne respecte pas les droits de l'homme et
alors les Ouigours mais comment se fait
mais c'est pas à se motif là que les
Américains désignent la Chine comme un
ennemi quand Nickson était singer vont à
Pékin 72 la Chine n'est pas une
démocratie
je crois qu'il vaut mieux être chinois
aujourd'hui qu'en 72
dans les années 90 quand on reçoit
thanksaioping comme un seigneur ta Chine
ne respecte pas les droits de l'homme il
y a une crise passion autoritaire dans
une ping en fait ce qui déplaît aux
Américains c'est le rattrapage c'est le
fait que la Chine faisait 10 % du PIB
américain en 2001 lorsqu'elle adhère à
l'OMC et que
70%. et qu'en fait le pacte non écrit
qu'il y avait entre la Chine Etats-Unis
je ne conteste pas ta suprématie
mondiale la phrase de thanks ioping
c'était cacher sa force à tendre son
heure
effectivement et en même temps du côté
américain bon je regarde pas ce qui se
passe chez toi c'est chez toi donc tu
fais ce que tu veux bah ce pack est
rompu impartiments ou la Chine dit je
serai la première puissance mondiale
donc on met connaissez le proverbe quand
le sage montre la lune l'imbécile voit
le doigt donc quand noix de coco
donc quand les Américains parlent les
droits de l'homme je ne dis pas qu'il y
a pas de parler droit de l'homme et je
dis que c'est pas cela qu'il est
motivent ce qui les motive c'est de
n'être plus la première puissance
mondiale donc ils veulent contenir la
Chine c'est pour ça qu'ils disent
européens venez avec nous ça nous
concerne également alors que ça nous
concerne pas enfin je veux dire nous la
suprémationale c'était pas le problème
de l'Europe et qui disent aux
Australiens aux Anglais venez et
australiens sont très contents qu'on les
amène et les Britanniques sont très
contents parce que Johnson qui empêtré
dans plein d'affaires peut dire regardez
global Britain ça marche bien etc et moi
sur les droits de l'homme je suis le
meilleur je ne sais pas et donc il se
refait une virginité à bon compte donc
se faire une virginité à bon compte se
draper dans les temps d'arts de la vertu
diplomatique j'aide les droits de
l'homme les minorités ainsi de suite
vous êtes en train de nous dire en fait
que c'est
de la poudre de perlimpinpin
je ne dis pas qu'il y a pas des
dirigeants qui sont sincèrement
et
d'autres mais
je pense quand même que
l'évocation des droits de l'homme n'est
quand même très soudaine que l'évocation
du développement et de répandre la
civilisation était le masque d'appétit
écolo bon c'est
en 2003 on fait la guerre contre l'Irak
parce que c'est une dictature on dit on
regardait on a tout arrangé on va faire
une démocratie on fait pas la guerre
contre la Corée du Nord pourtant la
Corée du Nord n'est pas une démocratie
claire au contraire c'est pour ça qu'on
les a pas attaqué c'est pour ça que vous
avez attaqué
on est au 21e siècle Pascal Boniface
vous êtes vieux vous avez fait des
années je suis plus proche de la fin que
du début
je compte durer encore un peu longtemps
d'accord
comme Pascal Boniface si parce qu'elle
Boniface il devait décrire l'avenir pour
ses petits-enfants il dirait quoi ses
petits-enfants parce qu'elle manifeste
alors ces petits enfants majeurs
d'accord on peut rentrer avec des mots
qui vont bien en description ou en
quelle sauce ils vont être mangés
honnêtement on n'en sait rien
non non parce que ceux qui font la
prospective à 20 ans moi je voulais
faire je vous la fais à 5 ans là ok à 5
ans on est bien vous dites les petits
enfants adultes non mais 18 ans bon ok
bon bah d'ici le
le l'un des facteurs clés ça sera est-ce
que les Américains acceptent d'être
dépassés par la Chine ou pas
vous avez déjà votre réponse
oui mais comme les Chinois vont les
dépasser quand même comment ils vont
gérer ça quoi oui vous avez déjà votre
réponse non enfin ça sera pas forcément
la guerre non non mais ils vont ils vont
oui ils vont vriller ils m'ont pas
apprécié parce qu'ils ont toujours été
habitués à être la première puissance
mondiale qu'est-ce qui se passe quand un
gamin qui a été échoué pendant X ou lui
dit non et ben justement c'est là où les
Européens et les autres auront un rôle
pour les ramener à la raison
mettre la camisole non mais juste en
leur disant mais ça marche pas au truc
quoi justement en quittant cette
docilité mais ça marche pas
il faut voir les choses en face mais il
y a quand même pas il y a quand même et
l'autre le corollaire de ça est-ce que
les chinois à leur tour vont tomber dans
l'hubris
parce que alors en partie en partie
c'est déjà le cas mais ils disent nous
on n'a jamais eu on était jamais été
colonialiste etc
l'amiral X en œil il avait 300 bateaux
il était en Afrique il est revenu etc
mais donc voilà c'est ça c'est important
ce qui me rassure un petit peu dans ce
flot de mauvaises nouvelles c'est qu'il
y a quand même de plus en plus de gens
informés qui a de plus en plus de moyens
d'informations vous en faites partie
c'est que partout les gouvernements ont
perdu le monopole de l'information
quand Gorbatchev arrive au pouvoir
l'information des membres du colis de
bureau du PCUS elle est faite par six
mecs 10 mecs qui trient les dépêches
ils ont un pouvoir énorme
aujourd'hui à part en Corée du Nord en
Erythrée peut-être Rwanda vous avez
accès à d'autres informations que celle
du gouvernement
oui mais quand même mais je veux dire
mais comparons avec une situation qui
aurait été une situation de guerre
regarder la guerre du golf qui pourtant
était légal celle de 90 pour moi guerre
du Golf 90 guerre d'Irak 2003 on a quand
même dit la quatrième armée du monde
vous aviez les couveuses qui étaient
débranchés et que c'est la fille de
façon du Koweït qui me l'a raconté ça
enfin bon donc maintenant moi je veux
bien qu'il y a du fake news sur les
réseaux sociaux mais il y a vite les
moyens de démonter ces fake news donc on
a quand même des cadeaux d'information
qu'on n'avait pas et vous en faites
partie
vous faites partie de ceux qui brisaient
le monopole de disons à la fois des
gouvernements et des puissances d'argent
sur l'information grâce à notre
communauté voilà bon donc tout ceci pour
dire que même si encore beaucoup
d'aboutisse sur terre il y a quand même
de plus en plus de gens qui s'informent
et qui exercent leur esprit critique et
qui voit bien que
moi je fais beaucoup de conférences par
exemple alors je sais pas ce que lequel
vous allez me suivre jusqu'à quel point
j'ai choqué ceux qui dans l'école de
commerce
dans les facultés Sciences Po disons que
les jeunes étudiants il y a 20 ou 30 ans
ils étaient the best of the brightest
les meilleurs etc ils disaient on est
des Winners etc de plus en plus quand
même les jeunes étudiants cette
génération et consciente ils veulent pas
qu'il y ait du pognon certains peut-être
mais il y a plein de gens qui disent bah
si c'est uniquement pour gagner du
pognon et se faire chier au boulot ça
m'intéresse pas quand même plus de plus
de gens regardez les réflexions par
rapport au covid-19 etc et rien de plus
en plus de gens qui sont en réflexion
sur leur propre vie
et sur la moyenne d'information et ça
c'est un facteur d'espoir je peux casser
les rêves de vos petits enfants dites
cette jeune génération qui a décidé un
petit peu d'arrêter de manger la
bouillie prémaché qu'on leur servait on
envoie place plein sur les réseaux
sociaux ils viennent discuter avec nous
il nous témoigne un petit peu de ce qui
se passe dans leur cursus scolaire
ils vont pas avoir le temps le temps qui
prennent les postes à responsabilités
qui dégagent
les
taupes planquées depuis des années
concocté leurs copains de taupinière et
qu'on fait leur petit nid tranquille
ils peuvent s'exprimer créer un rapport
de force je veux dire ça marche le
rapport de force aussi donc ils peuvent
créer un rapport de force
et faire pression alors attention je dis
pas que ça va être facile on va le faire
en cinq ans etc mais si on peut pas dire
que c'est perdu on peut pas dire que
c'est foutu on peut pas mais
on peut
par exemple moi si je vois un jeune
Arabe qui me dit quand même je souffre
comment ça veut rien dire en général
qui peut être étudiant ou employé peu
importe il a la même discrimination
je veux dire il risque autant les
contrôles de police il y a pas marqué
son front qu'il est étudiant ou son père
etc bon ils me disent bon on est discuté
oui et ils ont plus de chances d'être
contrôlé et d'être emmerdé que mes
enfants mais moi je leur dis mais quand
moi j'étais à Mantes au lycée du Val
Fourré il y avait pas un arabe peut-être
un je sais pas mais bon oui si Malika
dans ma classe parce qu'ils avaient tous
au lycée technique donc il y a aussi des
progrès qui sont faits il y a quand même
une voilà donc ça crée des crispations
donc en fait il faut toujours je pense
si on veut lutter contre tous les
phénomènes que vous dénoncez je pense
qu'il faut tenir les choses par debout
c'est à la fois voir le chemin qui reste
à accomplir et voir le chemin qui a été
fait
si vous ne voyez que les chemins qui
restent à faire vous les couragez on y
arrivera jamais etc si vous dites le
chemin était fait et on peut s'arrêter
du coup tout va bien on s'arrête là non
d'accord les deux l'important
l'important c'est pas la destination
c'est le chemin on est d'accord
mais
j'ai l'impression que vous avez des
lunettes roses concernant notre état à
l'heure actuelle
voir ce qu'on a fait et voir ce qu'on va
faire
c'est pour se mobiliser d'accord c'est
pour se mobiliser voir ce qui reste à
faire parce que les chantiers sont
énormes il y a des prêcheurs de haine
dans ce pays
pas tous ceux qui pensent que notamment
l'Islam et la République sont pas
compatibles et ils sont de gauche ou de
droite ils sont pas que de droite ils
sont pas que d'extrême droite certains
se revendiquent de gauche est présente
l'islam comme une menace pour la
République etc donc bon on a quand même
des chantiers énormes par rapport à cela
retrouver du vivre ensemble etc mais
l'époque République ou la religion n'a
rien à [__] là dedans
moi mon slogan c'est ni dieu ni maître
je suis plutôt bon donc je dis plutôt
Léo Ferré etc je ne suis pas croyant
mais ça me fait pas chier que d'autres
croient tant qu'ils viennent pas
m'emmerder moi à me forcer à croire
donc s'il y a des gens qui veulent
croire c'est moi je veux dire j'ai pas
envie qu'on m'emmerde j'ai pas envie
d'emmerder les autres tant qu'on vient
pas empiéter sur mes libertés
revenons la conversation pour vos petits
enfants l'avenir économique pour aux
petits enfants vous le voyez bien pas
bien l'euro toujours là
oh oui l'euro toujours là
un des défis important pour nos
petits-enfants c'est le défi de
l'intelligence artificielle
parce que est-ce que ça va conduire à
rendre la vie plus facile à permettre
plus facilement de satisfaire les
besoins ou est-ce que ça va permettre à
deux trois génies de toquer en même
temps d'aller vivre sur une île ou
paieront pas d'impôts et oui métro tous
ceux qui sont pas d'accord avec eux au
chômage parce que ils ont des robots
pour les servir faire la façon dont on
pourra ou non maîtriser cela ne pas être
un enjeu sociétal et géopolitique très
importante et on voit bien quand même
que
Elon Musk et les autres ne sont pas des
biens enfin ils ont à la fois rendu
immense service militaire par les moyens
qui mettent à leur disposition mais on
voit que le fait de même pas supporter
qu'un syndicat dans entreprise sous 70
ans libéral est quand même pour le moins
contradictoire et donc si effectivement
il pense que tout le travail peut être
fait par les robots on fait quoi les
armées de chômeurs donc là la juste
répartition des bénéfices
que l'intelligence artificielle va
produire et quand même un enjeu majeur
sur lequel il y a assez peu de débats
est-ce que vous avez des livres à nous
conseiller ça dépend sur quoi alors la
cuisine du bœuf bourguignon ah là
j'aurais ben écoutez sur la géopolitique
je serai que vous conseiller les miens
en priorité bien sûr c'est interdit ça
ouais mais
quel est
les bouquins qui ont compté pour vous
pour vous forger votre opinion ou
récemment ou pour penser contre
vous-même alors les deux gros bouquins
d'arary sapiens c'est deus
le bouquin de Stéphane Walt the hello
Nintendo
l'enfer des bonnes intentions il montre
comment la diplomatie morale États-Unis
conduit à des catastrophes
le nouveau 21ème siècle de Jean-Marie
Guéno qui est paru récemment était aussi
un bon bouquin je pourrais en citer
plusieurs
les bouquins de Kissinger quand j'étais
étudiant bon quand même marqué c'est le
Brigitte qui aussi par leur intelligence
j'aime bien lire ce qui a écrit Védrine
aussi mais enfin on est proche donc
c'est un peu normal
non il y a des j'aime bien lire les
bouquins de chaillants parce que c'est
puissant etc
il y a quand même plein de bouquins
effectivement vous les fermez vous dites
j'ai quand même
là je viens de terminer un bouquin
d'Alexandre de Gaulle la Russie qui est
vraiment très bien aussi j'ai à peu près
deux bouquins par semaine
donc
et sur bouquin je peux pas avoir les
donc j'ai sur Limbo beaucoup etc et
c'est
pour moi vraiment je sais qu'aujourd'hui
les gens s'informent plus tellement par
les livres sauf ici bon mais je pense
que le livre est quand même
quelque chose qui vous permet un peu une
réflexion que vous aimez dans votre
émission sur le temps long quoi le livre
c'est le temps long
est-ce que vous voulez qu'on parle d'un
sujet
parce que vous avez un sujet que vous
voulez aborder avec nous
Léo Ferré
et alors les îles Salomon
la Chine et les îles Salomon est-ce que
on va on va digresser un petit peu
est-ce que les Australiens nous ont pas
acheté nos sous-marins parce qu'en fait
on allait leur vendre des vrais merdes
et que ils sont ils se sont rendus
compte grâce aux États-Unis qui leur ont
expliqué que eux leur sous-marins eux
ils avaient des super super Templiers et
que les nôtres maquillage relou c'est
exactement ce qu'il leur a expliqué sauf
que le temps le temps qu'il les aille le
prix qu'ils vont les payer des détails
beaucoup de gens ont enfin les ceux qui
étaient de la minorité on dit ah on va
se fâcher avec les Chinois de façon
excessive et inutile et de on n'a pas
besoin de ça et on va se couper d'une
alternative etc alors ici ça le monde la
Chine elle a une influence dans les
c'est pour pas cher
c'est pour pas cher j'étais dans un
coloc en polysie il y a deux ans si on
influence chinoise on s'emmerde pas bon
et j'étais invité je pouvais pas refuser
et
au moins votre hébergement sur place ah
bah non je suis invité
non ça c'est une règle d'ailleurs
personne ne l'iris ne se déplace il faut
que les risques s'engagent des frais
si on se déplace on paye l'hébergement
et c'est la règle des Colocs
des journalistes par contre
hébergement
petit donc en fait pour revenir à nos
moutons les chinois déploignent du
bossile influent dans tout le Pacifique
parce que c'est pas cher et c'est des
voix à l'ONU
c'est des présences et sur les routes de
la soie c'est les constellations là il y
a eu une sorte de réveil un peu brutale
des Américains qui sont dit voilà
qu'est-ce qui se passe et donc qui vont
effectivement tenter de le faire mais
regardez en Afrique les Chinois on va
une présence ils ont quadruplés décupler
leur présence tout d'un coup l'Europe
s'est dit ah ben il faut qu'on s'y mette
aussi parce que pendant la crise de
covid-19 les réactions de certains
ministres c'est-à-dire monsieur
scandaleux la Chine met en scène son
aide c'est pas bien etc nous quand un
ministre déversé un sac de riz
Apocalypto c'était pas de la mise en
scène bien sûr vraiment
etc
et le l'Europe s'est réveillé en disant
fauteuil qu'on soit un peu plus présente
en Afrique parce que il suffit pas de
dénoncer
la présence des autres si nous-mêmes
nous sommes absents nos pensées de la
sécurisation du collier de perles par
les États-Unis
vous avez compris ma question tout à
fait alors expliquez là pour notre
communauté en fait il y a c'est toutes
les possessions les îles enfin la
ceinture autour de la Chine que les
États-Unis sur lequel ils veulent faire
du containement en réalité qui la
principale route énergétique de la Chine
de l'époque parce que il y a quand même
75 80% de l'approvisionnement
énergétique chinois passe par là quoi
donc bon et les Chinois disent est-ce
que vous aimerez qu'on envoie des
bateaux dans les Caraïbes
et les mécanismes non mais nous on est
là parce qu'on a des alliés et les
chinois ne veulent pas se laisser faire
pour l'instant
c'est gérable parce qu'il y a pas de
confrontation mais rappelez-vous en 2001
un avion américain a un peu frotté trop
près à l'avion chinois il a dû atterrir
en catastrophe sur une île chinoise les
Chinois l'ont désossé l'ont rendu enfin
je veux dire des fois si les bateaux se
frottent ça pilote
et donc oui il peut y avoir
pas une guerre pas d’advertance mais il
peut y avoir des
renforcement enfin je veux dire on est
dans une course aux armements
mais pas depuis la guerre en Ukraine ça
vous fait pas penser à une bande de gros
débiles quand même c'est rien la guerre
partout on va remettre des bombes on va
remettre du budget et on continue comme
en 14 et voilà tranquille connaissez le
proverbe la prochaine la prochaine
guerre ce sera coup de bâton
mais votre avis entre vous et moi on va
parler entre franchouillard
non mais en train on est en train de
mettre des billets je trouve que cette
course aux armements à laquelle on
assiste depuis maintenant une quinzaine
d'années je veux dire on a parlé des
dividendes de la paix après la fin du
non soviétique il y a une légère
diminution des dépenses militaires très
vite la course a repris
et
en fait cette course on en connaît la
ligne de départ on n'en connaît pas la
ligne d'arrivée les dépenses militaires
américaines c'est grosso modo 280
milliards de dollars en 2001 aujourd'hui
on est à 800
est-ce que ils sont plus en sécurité non
des Chinois suivent ils suivent pas
autant parce que les Chinois eux ils ont
compris que l'URSS est morte
d'avoir voulu suivre la course aux
armements lancés par les Américains donc
les choix ils s'en sont à 200-220 230
milliards
mais ils ont aussi compris qu'il faut
quand même dire qu'ils sont pas
comparables
d'accord parce que moi quand je fais
construire un bateau en Chine ça me
coûte 5 fois moins cher que quand je le
fais dans le Delaware ouais mais je
pense que c'est aussi en parité de
pouvoir d'achat etc enfin qui vous est
arrivé
votre petite étrillage par ircemment
l'ambassadeur il vous a appelé en disant
alors Pascal Le Canard il était pas très
bon ce midi ou non lui il a dû rigoler
hein
c'était pas je veux dire que les
Français s'engueulent etc non ce qui
était un peu scandale dans cette affaire
c'est que si vous accusez quelqu'un vous
allez au moins le consulter pour dire je
vais t'accuser de ça
qu'est-ce que tu en penses et comment il
préférait l'avocat comment tu te défends
bon et en fait quand il y a eu les
premiers échos dans le monde où je suis
interdit de séjour mais là pour parler
de mal en moi de moi en mal ils étaient
très contents je vois l'article je
téléphone au patron de dire ça mais je
dis mais pourquoi j'ai pas reçu ce
rapport d'abord et je vois le lire quand
même puisque je suis mis en cause il m'a
dit ah bah non si je te l'avais envoyé
tu l'avais envoyé l'ambassadeur de Chine
c'est vraiment
c'est du grand n'importe quoi
maintenant un petit coup de fil de
l'avocat
j'ai hésité
il faut pas hésiter dans ces cases
il fallait être sûr de gagner la
diffamation ou c'est j'ai fait les
procès j'en ai gagné j'en ai perdu je
veux dire je pas non plus c'est un peu
mais j'ai hésité j'ai hésité au nom de
l'iris effectivement et je
ça aurait été un peu amusant peut-être
question pour un étudiant en relation
internationale quel impacterait les
experts en prospective ont-ils sur les
décisions
il faut être nid dans lubrie ni dans le
misérabilisme
ont participé au débat d'idées
nourrit les décideurs qui sont
influencés petitement par les uns et les
autres donc en fait il y a une sorte de
grande casserole où chacun vient mettre
ses ingrédients tout ça fait une grande
soupe et ça infuse un petit peu donc ce
n'est pas nous qu'ils ont la politique
c'est pas nous qui influençons la
politique mais en participant des bas
d'idées et en activant des réflexions
etc on peut de temps en temps jouer un
rôle modeste on est des dizaines des
centaines etc donc il y a pas en fait il
y a pas un organisme hyper intelligent
qui réfléchirait et du coup des
exécutants qui iraient à maintien tel
film tank a fait ça donc on va faire
pareil
question Internet et que penses-tu de la
situation de Taïwan
et ben Taïwan est dans une situation à
la fois
inconfortable et confortable
c'est-à-dire que pour l'instant bon il y
aura pas de réification pacifique de la
Chine le système de système une nation
inventé par tenks ioping pour rencontre
l'avait été pour appâter Taïwan
c'était le hors-d'oeuvre en fait ils ont
fait l'occidental quoi voilà et vu ce
qui se passe à Hong Kong des tailles ont
bien compris que s'ils sont réunifiés
ils seront moins libres surtout que
finalement les Hong Kong avait déjà
quelques libertés mais taïwanais ils ont
des liens étaient totales c'est un des
pays les plus libres du monde avec une
des vrais sociétés civiles c'est
vraiment bon un vrai pays etc les
changements de régime etc des problèmes
avec l'ambassade de Chine
et mais bon et du coup
voilà je mangerai autre chose
et donc
en fait il y a un statu quo qui
satisfait tout le monde
Taïwan ne proclame pas son indépendance
la Chine dit qu'un jour ils seront
réunifiés on a le temps 2049 et et la
Chine fait pression pour que les 15 pays
qui reconnaissent encore Taïwan leur
connaissent plus retire leur ambassade
mais nous on n'a pas eu d'ambassade mais
on a une délégation donc c'est et en
France il y a pas un ambassadeur de
Taïwan mais il y a représentant de
Taïwan
donc c'est alors c'est vrai que Taïwan
principal OMS c'était pas bon Taiwan
était à la FIFA au CIO donc ça ils
peuvent le faire non parce que on impose
moins les volontés au CIO et la FIFA etc
et donc
par rapport au sud de la Chine non c'est
là ça marcherait plus là-dessus et donc
pour l'instant en fait et ben ça tient
quoi ça tient
est-ce que la Chine voudra voyant que
pacifiquement il y aura pas de
réunification faire une vérification par
la force
si elle le faisait elle casserait
sa croissance
et donc elle satisfait le patriote mais
elle désespéré le consommateur
donc pour l'instant les Chinois pensent
que il vaut mieux attendre surtout que
si c'est un objectif
qui est vraiment sacrée
bah ça peut sans que personne ne soit
avexé ni humiliée attendre 2049 et 100e
anniversaire de la prise du pouvoir
une question internet à laquelle on a
déjà répondu un signe tant que n'est-il
pas un lobby non non vous avez alors un
signe temps qui sera Nobile ne serait
pas un signe tant que vous avez des bien
caché mais voilà non mais disons que
vous avez les fausses ONG vous avez bon
vous avez voilà et vous avez
effectivement des films tanks qui ne
sont que les portes-parents d'intérêt
parfois ONG vous entendez une ONG qui
prend que l'argent public mais qui roule
en super non
vous parlez d'une super ONG qui est
projetée pour aider les petits pauvres
en Afrique mais qui fait du
renseignement sur place
ça peut exister non je parle par exemple
des structures qui se présentent comme
étant des ONG mais qui sont des membres
romans d'industrie ou d'entreprise ou
d'état qui se déguisent en AM parce que
c'est plus facile c'est à dire que voilà
on va
si bien sûr
mais certains le sont et d'autres font
leur boulot de centre de recherche en
essayant de réfléchir auprès des
internationales pour vous quels sont les
symptômes lobby
disons qu'elle est sington qui sont des
signes tank étatique donc forcément ils
peuvent pas dans certains pays ils
peuvent pas se libérer de fond
d'influence au service de leur
gouvernement mais voilà on le sait donc
on le on le bon après vous avez des fois
des structures complètement bidon qui
sont créés pour
répondre aux services de certains
gouvernements bon on arrive quand même
un peu à les repérer une fois encore je
crois que ce qui compte c'est la taille
la visibilité la cohérence l'ancienneté
et bon le fait quand même que et puisse
y avoir des expressions différentes dans
le même Clinton
bon on est d'accord il y a des fermes à
trop le Russe on est d'accord il y a des
signes temps pro russe on est d'accord
il y a des Sims tanks pro chinois on est
d'accord il y a des organes d'influence
de trolls de ce que vous voulez chinois
on est d'accord
pourquoi on dit jamais la même chose
pour les États-Unis l'Arabie saoudite le
Qatar la Pologne alors les États-Unis
parce que c'est chez nous parce que
c'est
la famille voilà c'est la famille et ça
va alors
vous savez très bien que
nos services qui
nous servent lesquels les services de
renseignement
les services en général bon on regarde
le reste regarde régulièrement
s'il y a des pays qui ne serait-ce que à
travers les films tanks et c'est de
faire de l'influence
c'est leur boulot
et quels sont les gens qui sont invités
où vont les gens etc ils vous disent
ouais voilà etc enfin bon donc il
surveille un peu
et j'ai mais en fait pourquoi vous
faites pas ça avec les Américains oui
non c'est nos alliés
les alliés que les autres
et après on perd des sous-marins et où
la BNP se fait qu'on ait 9 milliards
est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations
on a oublié de parler d'un truc
vachement important
Algérie Maroc ça chauffe oulala
on est autant regarder par les Algériens
que par les Marocains
donc il se passe quoi Algérie Maroc il y
a un engrenage très dangereux
un engrenage très dangereux parce que
bon il y a une tradition l'Algérie se
vit comme le pays qui s'est libéré
lui-même par les armes pays phares du
tiers-monde etc le Maroc comme un pays
tranquille
occidental donc déjà ils ont des récits
de leur accession à l'indépendance et de
leur premier pas
différents dans la période plus récente
ça s'écorce pourquoi parce que l'Algérie
est en difficulté le Irak
à pouvoir quand même qui est un petit
peu en difficulté par rapport à sa
population etc qui doit faire face et
qui du coup bah des fois besoin bon et
puis le Maroc effectivement il y a eu
des déclarations sur la Kabylie qui ont
très franchement des plus aux Algériens
et puis l'accord avec Israël entre le
Maroc et Israël et bien alors c'est une
victoire pour le Maroc parce que du coup
les États-Unis reconnaissent la
souveraineté du Maroc sur le Sahara que
la grande cause marocaine mais en même
temps les Algériens voient les
Israéliens venir les observer et que ça
développe un discours ça va encore
radicaliser leur opposition puisque
l'Algérie dit nous on est vraiment les
maîtres du tiers-monde les champions du
droit des peuples de même on fait ça
pour les Palestiniens on fait ça pour
les sars oui et les Marocains ont vendu
leur âme aux Israéliens par le cul des
Palestiniens et en finissait oui donc
cet accord qui était que les Marocains
se disent nous on a gagné beaucoup on va
voir les accords économiques etc voilà
les investissements surtout on a les
Américains parce qu'en fait la route de
Washington passe par Tel Aviv quoi donc
sa vie c'est bon et donc
cet accord a des conséquences sur la
crispation des relations entre l'Algérie
et le Maroc qui sont très dommageables
ça va se taper
non je ne pense pas mais je pensais pas
non plus que la Russie irait en guerre
contre l'Ukraine mais en fait
logiquement non parce que personne n'y a
intérêt mais une fois qu'on a dit ça on
sait que ça peut comme arriver parce
qu'il y a plein de guerre qui se sont
produites alors que les gens n'y avaient
pas intérêt et que dans des situations
aussi tendues que celle-là une
provocation mal digérée
un faux pas peut provoquer un conflit
qu'on a ensuite du mal à être donc c'est
très dangereux ce que vous avez un
conseil pour les jeunes générations une
bouteille à la mer quelque chose de
moins périssable que la parole de nos
politiques
ouais
bosser en restant ouvert sur les autres
vivez avec les autres bosser parce que
c'est le boulot quand même qui fait la
différence c'est quand même voilà moi je
suis pas un héritier j'ai bossé quoi
donc faut bosser mais surtout faut
rester à l'écoute des autres il y a des
pires qu'une vie solitaire enfin je veux
dire ces boules la vie qu'on est avec
les autres qu'on a les amis qu'on peut
rigoler ensemble etc donc en fait il
faut trouver un équilibre là dedans et
ceux qui arrivent à le trouver des mecs
qui ne font que rigoler avec les copains
c'est un peu chiant les mecs qui ne font
que bosser c'est ultra chiant mais quand
on est épanoui dans un boulot qu'on aime
bien et que on est dans une pour un
collectif etc la vie est quand même
plutôt agréable
Pascal Boniface merci merci à vous
[Musique]